İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 3 Şubat 2025 çarşamba günü. 60. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Bugün yeni bir konuya başlayacağız. Uzunca sürecek bir konu. Hatta kursun geri kalan derslerinin hepsi olmasa da çok büyük çoğunluğu bu konuya ilişkin.
Arkadaşlar konu başlığımız genel olarak concurrency. Tabi C++ odağında.
Buradaki concurrency sözcüğünün Türkçede birebir bu yazılımsal anlamda bir karşılığı olduğunu düşünmüyorum.
Yani tabi Türkçemiz çok zengin çok fazla sözcük var. Ama bu anlamda bazıları eş güdüm diye çeviriyor.
Bazıları biraz yanlış olabilecek şekilde eş zamanlılık diye çeviriyor.
Fakat bizim için önemli olan İngilizcesi burada kast edilen bir programın o ya da bu nedenle belirli bir zaman dilimi içinde birden fazla işi ayrı ayrı yapabilmesi.
Tahmin edilebileceği gibi bu konuyla ilgili temel araç setimiz threadler.
Arkadaşlar thread sözcüğünün de Türkçede doğrudan belki oturmuş bir karşılığı yok.
Bazıları atış diyor, bazıları iş yükü diyor, bazıları birebir çevirip iplik diyor.
Çünkü öyle bir arkadaşlar analojiyle zaten oluşturulmuş bu sözcük.
Yiğitince diyor ki hocam real time operating system ile bir benzerliği var mı?
Tabii ki var. Sonuçta real time, gerçek zamanla çalışan programlar, yani gerçek zamanda oluşan eventlere cevap veren programlar çoğunlukla zaten çok threadli, multi-thread programlar.
Genel olarak threadleri kullanarak yazılan programlara böyle popüler olarak multi-thread programlar deniyor.
Burada concurrency sözcüğü işte threadlerin kullanılmasıyla tipik olarak programın belirli bir zaman diliminde birden fazla işi birlikte yapması anlaşılıyor.
Çoğunlukla arkadaşlar, hocam bu arada threadler hakkında önceden bilmeli miyiz?
Valla doğrusu isterseniz önceden bilginizin olması tabii belirleri bir fayda sağlar.
Ama biz şimdi Resul C++'ın standart kütüphanesi odaklı gideceğimiz için bu konudaki bilgi eksikliği başlangıçta en azından çok da önemli değil.
Ben temel bazı noktalara değineceğim.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi burada İngilizce'de bazı uzmanlar şu iki terimi birbirinden ayırıyor.
Biri concurrency, diğeri paralelizm.
Ben katılmasam da, yani ben buradaki efendim anlam farkına, nüansa katıldığımı söyleyemem.
Fakat birçok kişi concurrent niteleyicisiyle paralel, Türkçe karşılığıyla paralel niteleyicisi arasına bir anlamsal fark yüklüyor.
İşte bu resim mesela o anlamsal farkı gösteriyor.
Arkadaşlar, concurrent olması ve paralel olması tamamen onlara göre aynı şey değil.
Yani örneğin şöyle düşünün, ben saat 12 ile 2 arasında, 14 arasında şunları yapmış olabilirim değil mi?
Hem diyelim ki birileri bir süre fitness salonuna gittim, orada çalıştım.
Sonra birileri bir süre yemek yedim.
Sonra tekrar bilgisayarın başına oturdum.
Şimdi bu yaptığım işler bu zaman diliminde 12-2 arasında yapıldı.
Ama şöyle de yapılmış olabilir değil mi?
Mesela önce efendim spor salonuna gittim, fitness salonuna gittim, sonra yemek yedim, sonra tekrar fitness salonuna gittim.
Yani belirli bir zaman diliminde arkadaşlar işlemler birlikte yapılıyor.
Ama birlikte yapılmasıyla eş zamanlı, yani İngilizcesiyle simultaneously yapılması aynı şey değil.
Mesela buradaki resimde böyle bir analoji yapmış.
Demiş ki iki tane kuyruk var, bir tane espresso makinesi var.
O zaman buradan ikisinin ayrı ayrı iki kuyruğun ayrı ayrı espresso alması mümkün değil.
Bir biri alacak, diğeri bekleyecek.
Diğer kuyruktan biri alacak ya da birden fazlası alacak.
Yani bir zaman diliminde sadece bir tane makine olduğu için makineden bir kişi espresso olabilir.
Ama paralelliğince daha çok kast edilen, tekrar söylüyorum herkes bu terminolojiyi kullanmak zorunda değil.
Bunların gerçekten eş zamanlı olması.
Yani örneğin iki tane ayrı kuyruk var ama iki tane de ayrı espresso makinesi var.
Bir kuyruk bir espresso makinesinden espresso alırken diğer kuyruktaki bir kişi de diğer makineden alıyor.
Yani burada gerçek anlamda bir eş zamanlılık var.
Aynı zaman diliminde değil, aynı anda ayrı iki işlem birden yapılıyor.
Şimdi bu bilgisayarlar söz konusu olduğunda ikisini de işletim sistemi tarafından yapılabiliyor.
Ama gerçek paralelizmden bahsedebilmemiz için birden fazla işlemci ya da birden fazla çekirdek olması gerekiyor.
Yoksa gerçek anlamda böyle bir paralellik söz konusu olmaz.
Mesela korulardan biz Türkçe'de çekirdek terimini kullanıyoruz.
Çekirdeklerden biri bir işlemi yaparken başka bir çekirdek başka bir işlemi yapıyor gibi.
Ama tek çekirdek, tek işlemci tek çekirdek varsa aslında zaman paylaşımlı olarak işlemci işletim sisteminin sağladığı olanakla biraz bir kodu çalıştırıyor.
Sonra İngilizce'de task switching deniyor.
Öbür koddan bir kısım çalıştırıyor, context switching ya da.
Sonra tekrar öbür koddan çalıştırıyor.
Böyle bir ondan, bir bundan.
Burada işletim sisteminin bazı parametreleriyle bunu belirli düzende ayarlayabiliyorsunuz.
İşte bu concurrency ama yani concurrency paralel olmak zorunda değil.
Şimdi ben işletim sistemi tarafına girmek istemiyorum ama
Haan Bey'in bizim benim de kuzen oluyor dernette Unix Linux Sistem programlama notları var.
Orada işletim sistemi düzeyinde zaten 500 saat mini okurs.
Bu multi-trading, multi-processing bütün bu kavramlar çok ayrıntılı olarak anlatılıyor.
Şimdi benim aslında üstünde durmak istediğim doğal olarak C++'da bunun uygulanması.
Arkadaşlar şimdi önce şunu söyleyerek başlayalım.
Modern C++'dan önce yani C++'ın 2011 standartından önce bu multi-trading programlama dilin standart araçlarıyla yapılmıyordu.
Yani modern C++'da belki de dile eklenen en büyük yenilik devrim niteliğinde concurrency bileşenlerinin artık işletim sisteminden bağımsız standart olması.
Ve bu çok şeyi değiştirdi.
Bilim formal o kadar çok tanımını değiştirdi ki mesela daha önce formal olarak oluşturulmuş,
bunu da ilerleyen saatlerden açıklayacağım, bir memory model, Türkçe gibi okuyorum, memory model yoktu.
Ama bu concurrency öğelerinin, multi-thread programlama ilişkin öğelerin formal olarak tanımlanması,
belirli garantilerin verilmesi için bir memory model oluşturuldu C++ için.
Burada bence hani demin Resul sordu ya burada trepleri vesaireleri çok iyi bilmek zorunda mıyız?
Burada bence kritik olarak bilinmesi gereken birkaç tane nokta var.
Artık geri kalanını size bırakıyorum.
Birincisi aslında C++ birçok programlama dilinde olduğu gibi C++'ın modern C++'a eklenen kütüphaneleri
bir arkadaşlar wrapper niteliğinde aslında birçok işletim sistemine bağlı hizmetler için
standart kütüphanemiz bir wrapper görevi, sarmalayıcı görevi görüyor.
Mesela dosya işlemleri böyle değil mi?
Dosya işlemleri, file operations işte geçen derslerden birinin konusuydu.
O da işletim sisteminin verdiği bir hizmet.
Ama biz aşınabilirlik sağlamak için C'de de C++'da da işletim sisteminin sistem fonksiyonlarını
ya da işte API'lerini doğrudan çağırmak yerine aslında onları bir şekilde çağıran C++'ın
ya da C'nin standart fonksiyonlarını, burada tabii işin içine neler de giriyor, sınıflarını kullanıyoruz.
Şimdi bu bir yandan bir fayda sağlıyor.
Bu kesin çünkü her şeyin standart olması.
Yani örneğin işletim sistemiyle ilgili hiçbir şey bilmese bile
işletim sisteminin sistem fonksiyonlarına hiç dokunmadan
C++'ın standart kütüphanesinin birleşenleriyle
bir multitrack program yazabilir miyim?
Kesinlikle yazabilirim.
Ama şunu da söylemek gerekiyor.
Her ne kadar, her standartta
standartın verdiği destek daha artsa da
bu concurrency ile ilgili işletim sisteminin doğrudan sistem fonksiyonlarını,
API'lerini çağırarak işimizi görmek
çok daha ince, çok daha fazla bir kontrol sağlıyor.
Yani şu soruyu sorsak
işletim sisteminin
kendi fonksiyonlarını, kendi API'lerini çağırarak
yapabileceğimiz her şeyi
C++'ın bu
red kütüphanesiyle, concurrency kütüphanesiyle yapabilir miyiz?
Cevap kesinlikle hayır.
Ama seni nasıl söylemek gerekiyor arkadaşlar?
İşte o her yeni standartla
yapamayacağımız işlerin sayısı da azalıyor
ya da miktarı da azalıyor.
Belki de bundan sonraki
gelecekteki standartlarda
bu neredeyse
ihmal edilebilecek
bir yüzdeye düşecek.
Mesela
C++'ın standart kütüphanesini kullanarak
C++ 26'yı saymıyorum
threadlerin
önceliğini değiştirebilir miyim?
Mesela bir thread'e daha yüksek öncelik
bir thread'e daha düşük öncelik verebilir miyim?
Cevap hayır.
Ama
sistem fonksiyonlarını kullanarak
bunu yapabilir miyim?
Cevap evet.
Dolayısıyla
işletim sisteminin verdiği olanakların
hepsini doğrudan kullanamıyorum.
Bunu baştan söyleyelim.
Ama
çok iyi bir
sistem fonksiyonu derken
işletim sisteminin kendi fonksiyonlarından bahsediyorum.
İşletim sisteminin de fonksiyonları var değil mi?
İşletim sisteminin ne olduğuna bağlı olarak
bunlara
system calls
Windows'a
Windows'un apileri deniyor.
Siz
aslında dosya işlemleri için
dinamik bellek yönetimi için
arada sarmalayıcı bir katman olmasaydı
biz işletim sisteminin
sistem fonksiyonlarını kullanacaktık.
Ya da
buna çok yakın seviyede
işte mesela
Unix, Linux kökenli sistemlerde
p-tread kütüphanesini kullanacaktık.
Ama şimdi bunları kullanmadan
doğrudan
standart C++ kullanarak
multi-tread programları
yazabiliyoruz.
Arkadaşlar
ama burada şöyle de bir güzellik yapmışlar.
Yani bence bu
güzel bir tasarım.
Diyelim ki
C++'ın standart araçlarını
kullanarak
multi-tread bir program yazıyorum.
Yani threadleri kullanan bir program yazıyorum.
ama birerli bir yerde
işletim sisteminin
fonksiyonlarını çağırmam gerekiyor.
Çünkü
istediğim işi
doğrudan yapacak
C++ fonksiyonu yok.
Ama
örneğin
Windows'un bir
apisi var onun için.
bu durumda
şöyle bir güzellik yapmışlar.
Arkadaşlar
kütüphanenin
öğelerinin
hemen hepsi
İngilizce karşılığıyla
kütüphanedeki
isimsel karşılığıyla
bir
native handle veriyor.
C'deki handle sistemini biliyorsunuz.
Dolayısıyla
o handle'ı
kullanarak
siz
gereken yerde
doğrudan
standart kütüphanenin
öğelerini değil de
o handle
vasıtasıyla
işletim sisteminin
fonksiyonlarını
çağırabiliyorsunuz.
Mesela
ilerleyen dakikalarda
öyle bir örnek
ya da saatlerde
öyle bir örnek göstereceğim.
Mesela
bir thread'e
öncelik vermek için
gerçekten
kütüphanemizin
verdiği
handle'ı
bu tabi
derleyiciye bağlı
çünkü işletim sistemine
bağlı.
handle'ı
kullanacağım.
Arkadaşlar
şu sorunun cevabını da
yine
size bırakıyorum.
Allah'a bırakıyorum
demek gibi oldu ama
hangi sorunun
cevabını
efendim
neden
thread kullanıyor?
Yani
thread kullanımının
faydası ne?
Hangi
uygulamalarda
biz
thread kullanıyoruz?
Thread kullanarak
elimize ne geçiyor?
Yani buradaki
genel amaç ne?
Şimdi
büyük resmi de
sizin bir şekilde
çalışmanız
öğrenmeniz gerekiyor
çünkü bazı arkadaşlarım
zaten uzun süreden beri
bu alanda çalışıyorlar
ama bazı arkadaşlarım
C'nin de
standart
kütüphanesinde
doğrudan
efendim
en azından
C++
17'si
23 haricinde
onlar da
implement edilmiş durumda
değil
derleyiciler tarafından
doğrudan
bir thread
kütüphanesi yok.
Orada da yine
örneğin
P thread
kütüphanesini
kullanıyoruz.
Ama
bizim temel C kursuna
değil de
ilerisi
ve sistem
programlama
ya da
Unix
Minux
sistem
programlama
kursunda
anlatılıyor.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
threadlerin
kullanılmasında
gerçekten
birden fazla
amaç
olabilir.
Bunların
biri ya da
birden fazlası
bizim
thread
kullanmamızdaki
ana senaryo
olabilir.
Ben şöyle
hızlı bir şekilde
üstünden geçmek
için ki
eminim
bunların
çoğunu
ya biliyorsunuz
ya da
karşılaştınız.
Şöyle
biraz
yaklaştırayım.
Arkadaşlar
birincisi
CPU
bound
işlemler.
Yani
çok fazla
hesaplama yapılıyor
örneğin
bu
hesaplamaları
ayrı ayrı
threadler tarafından
yapılması
ayrı ayrı
threadlere
bölünmesi
yani
paralel
hale getirilmesi
işlemlerin
daha hızlı
daha kısa
sürede
yapılmasını
sağlıyor.
Yani örneğin
tek korda
bütün işlemleri
yapmak yerine
dört ayrı
korda
çekirdekte
işlemlerin
belirli kısmını
yapabiliyorsunuz.
Mesela
düşünün
bir
sort
algoritması
sıralama
efendim
birden
fazla
basamaktan
oluşuyor
ya da
bir kısmını
burada
arkadaşlar
veri
açısından
da bir bölme
yapılabilir
paralelleştirilirken
işlem açısından
da
bir bölme
yapılabilir.
Yani örneğin
bir thread
bir miktar
veriyi
işlerken
başka bir thread
başka bir
miktar
veriyi
işleyebilir
ya da
aynı
veri
üstünde
daha fazla
farklı
threadler
işlemler
yapıyor
olabilirler.
İşte
makine
öğrenimi
mesela
bu
algoritmik
trading
tarafında
arkadaşlar
multi thread
programlama
olmazsa
olmaz
diyebiliriz.
Çünkü
hesap
yoğun
ve
aynı zamanda
bir de
gerçek
zamanla
gelişiyor
olaylar.
Yani
siz
gerçek
zamanla
olarak
borsadan
verileri
alıp
ne yapabiliyorsunuz
ne yapmanız
gerekiyor
onlar üstünde
yüzlerce
binlerce
milyonlarca
aritmetik
hesap
yapmak
gerekiyor.
Bu arada
hemen
şunu da
söyleyin.
Emirhan
diyor ki
hocam tüm
çekirdeklere
dağıtınca
tüm
çekirdekleri
yüksek
oranda
utilize
ettiğimizde
bilgisayar
donabiliyor.
Tabii ki
şimdi
multi thread
programlama
ya da
threadleri
kullanma
her probleminde
çözümü
değil.
Getirdiği
avantajların
yanında
evet
kernel anlamında
kullanıyorum
çekirdek
biz
Türkçe'de
o terimi
kullanıyoruz
getirdiği
avantajların
yanında
dezavantajlar
da var
onlara da
değineceğim
çok kısa
tabi.
Mesela
dezavantajlar
kesinlikle
program
çok daha
karmaşık
hale geliyor.
Yani
single thread
bir programı
yazmakla
ya da
bir kodu
yazmakla
multi thread
kod yazmak
arasında
kodun
karmaşıklığı
açısından
ciddi
fark var.
Yani
single thread
olması durumunda
hiç göz önüne
almanız
gerekmeyen
bazı
senaryolar
örneğin
arkadaşlar
senkronizasyon
gibi
burada
çok
önem
kazanıyor.
yani
multi thread
programlamanın
kendine özgü
ayrı
problemleri
var.
Örneğin
arkadaşlar
deadlock
ya da
live
lock
dediğimiz
durumların
oluşması
gibi.
Ya da
işte
thread
kullanmanın
ayrı bir de
maliyeti
de var.
Yani
bazı
durumlarda
da siz
tamam
işlemlerin
bir kısmını
bir thread
yapsın
işlemlerin
bir kısmını
başka bir
thread
yapsın
diyorsunuz.
Ama
arka
planda
işletim
sistemi
tarafında
o threadlerin
oluşturulması
için
harcanan
maliyet
ona
değmeyebiliyor.
Evet.
İşte
Emrah'ın
diyor ki
data
race
endişesi
işte
en büyük
problemlerden
biri de
ilerleyen
saatlerde
yine
bizim
konumuz
olacak
arkadaşlar
data
race
ya da
ilk önce
race
condition
ve
data
race
dediğimiz
durumlar
ki
işte
buradaki
data
race
C++'ın
en tipik
tanımsız
davranış
durumlarından biri
ve ne kadar
dikkatli olursanız
olun
arkadaşlar
data race
den kaçınmak
çok kolay
değil.
Evet yani
en ufak bir
hatada
noktayı
gözden
kaçırdığınızda
bu
Türkçe'ye artık
birebir çevirmeyi
tercih etmiyorum
ama
data race
çok ilerleyen
saatlerden
konuşacağız
ama çok
kısaca şu
demek
aynı
kaynak
üstünde
birden fazla
thread'in
işlem yapması
mesela bir
değişken üstünde
ya da bir
bellek alanı
üstünde
ve bu
thread'lerden
en az
birinin
yazma
amaçlı
olması
yani
hepsi
veriye
okusa
herhangi bir
problem
olmayacak
ama
en az
biri
yazma
amaçlı
erişiyorsa
o bellek
alanına
ya da
o değişkene
işte o zaman
data race
dediğimiz
durum
oluşuyor
bu da
tanımsız
davranış
hepsine
örnekler
vereceğim
işte
şifreleme
ve kriptografi
tarafında
makine
öğrenimi
tarafında
bilimsel
hesaplamalar
tarafında
oyun
programlama
neredeyse
tamamen
artık
konkurrasinin
genel
kullanım
alanı
arkadaşlar
peki
burada
farklı
çekirdekleri
kullanarak
hesaplamaları
paralel
olarak
yapmak
ve işlem
süresini
azaltmak
bu arada
güzel bir
haberim de
var
C++'la
ilgili
arkadaşlar
biz
algoritmaları
görmüştük
ya
hani
algoritm
başlık
dosyasında
ve nümerik
başlık
dosyasındaki
algoritmaları
genelleştirilmiş
jenerik fonksiyonları
görmüştük
ya
modern
C++'la
birlikte
o
algoritmaların
hepsini
değil
ama
çok büyük
çoğunluğunu
hiç
uğraşmadan
fonksiyonlara
ilave
bir
argüman
geçerek
multi
thread
çalıştırabiliyorsunuz
bu da çok
büyük
avantaj
mesela ben
sort
algoritmasını
multi
thread
paralel
çalıştırmak
istiyorum
daha önce
görmediğimiz
sortun
ayrı bir
overloadu var
o
overloada
bir
argüman
geçerek
arka
planda
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
kodun
efendim
o işlemi
birden fazla
thread'e
dağıtarak
thread'leri hiç
doğrudan
kullanmadan
bu arada
yanlışlık olmasın
arkadaşlar
paralel olarak
yapılmasını
sağlayabiliyoruz
en tipik
ihtiyaçlardan
biri
bir iş çıkış
işlemlerinin
yoğun olduğu
uygulamalar
arkadaşlar
mesela
dosyadan
okuma
yapıyorsunuz
efendim
bir networkten
veri alıyorsunuz
ee
o dosyadan
okuma
yaparken
dosya
yazma
işlemi
yaparken
biz
bekleyecek
miyiz
ama
mesela
bir thread
bu
okuma
yazma
işlemlerini
yaparken
başka bir
thread
başka işlemleri
yapabiliyor
mesela
web sunucularının
hemen
hepsinde
bu
tabii ki
multi-thread
yapı
gerekiyor
veri
tabanı
işlemleri
dosya
işte
internette
web
scraping
dediğimiz
uygulamalar
doğrudan
tabii ki
birden fazla
thread
kullanıyor
evet
mesela
diyor ki
bir thread
a'dan veri
beklerken
diğer threadler
çalışmaya
devam ediyor
böylece
boşta
bekleme
durumu
engelleniyor
GUI programları
graphical user
interface
kullanan programlar
arkadaşlar
kullanıcı
arayüzünde
kullanıcıyla
programı
kullananla
bir etkileşim
var
ama
orada
kullanıcı
örneğin
bir seçim
yaparken
menüden
diğer işlemlerin
durmasını
istemeyiz
işte
burada
örneğin
bir thread
o
GUI tarafında
hallederken
diğer threadler
efendim
diğer işlemleri
yapıyor
uzun süren
işlemler
arka planda
çalıştırılabiliyor
en çok
kullanıldığı
yerlerden biri de
audio video
görüntü işleme
ve ses işleme
programları
bunların
hepsi
arkadaşlar
threadleri
etkin olarak
kullanıyor
ağır hesaplamalar
veya veri yüklemeleri
arka planda
çalışırken
kullanıcıyla
etkileşimi
kesmemiş
oluyorsunuz
ya da
kullanıcıyla
etkileşim
sağlarken
diğer işlemleri
durdurmak
zorunda
kalmıyorsunuz
işte az önce
arkadaşımın
söylediği
gerçek
zamanlı
sistemler
arkadaşlar
şimdi
gerçek
zamanlı
sistem
derken
illa
işletim
sisteminden
bahsedilmiyor
yani
gerçek
zamanda
bazı
eventlere
tepki vermeniz
gerekiyor
mesela borsa
işlemleri
böyle değil mi
ben
fiyat değişiyor
fiyat değiştiği
anda
algoritma
efendim
bir karar
mekanizmasını
kullanarak
bir emir
girecek
mesela şu
kadar
bitcoin
al
şu
fiyat
kadar
bitcoin
alsın
toplosu
şu
olsun
tek profit
bu
olsun
ama
diğer taraftan
dinamik olarak
fiyatlar
sürekli
değişiyor
anında
bizim programımızın
hesaplama yapıp
tepki
vermesi
gerekiyor
bu gerçek
zamanlı
işlemenin
söz konusu
olduğu birçok
alan var
endüstriyel
otomasyon
robotik
otonomi
dronelar
finansal
sistemler
algoritmik
trading
tarafı
böyle
burada
kritik
işlemler
ayrı ayrı
tradelerde
çalıştırıldığı
için
sistemin
tabii
programda
doğru yazılmışsa
hatasız
ve zamanında
çalıştırılması
sağlanabiliyor
oyun geliştirme
simülasyon
tarafı
mesela arkadaşlar
bu
sanal gerçeklik
tamamen
multi-threat
programlama
değil mi
oyun motorları
unreal engine
unity gibi
oradaki
fiziksel hesaplamalar
yani işin
engine kısmı
yapay zekaya
yönelik
hesaplamalar
yani aynı
zamanda
mesela bir taraf
gidiyor
yapay zekayla
efendim
bir işlem yapıyor
ama diğer taraf
matematiksel
hesaplama yapıyor
diğer taraf
fiziksel hesaplama yapıyor
ama bunlar
aynı zamanda
gerçekleştiriliyor
evet
arkadaşlar
arka plan
görevleri
mesela
bir yandan
şöyle olur ya
siz
programı
kullanırken
bir yandan da
bir yedekleme
yapılıyor
bir yandan
bir loglama
yapılıyor
bir yandan
bir yükleme
yapılıyor
mesela
java python
gibi dillerde
garbage collection
sistemi var
normal
kod koşarken
ayrı bir
thread
o garbage
collection'dan
sorumlu
artık kullanılmayan
nesnelerin
bizdeki gibi
değil
kullanılmayan
nesnelerin
hayatlarının
bitmesi
kaynakların
geri verilmesi
ayrı bir
threadle
o garbage
collection'ı
yöneten
threadle
gerçekleştiriliyor
o zaman
şöyle söyleyelim
multi-thread
programlama
her ne kadar
biz kursun
artık sonlarında
bu konuları
ele alıyor
olsak da
hayatın içinde
kaçınılmaz
olarak var
yani bundan
kaçma
şansımız
yok
ama
şimdi bizim
konumuz
burada
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesinin
nasıl kullanıldığı
buradaki
sınıflar
neler
ne işe yarıyor
bunların
üye fonksiyonu
neler
bunları kullanırken
nelere dikkat
etmemiz
gerekiyor
bunlar
işte az önce
dezavantajlar
demiştim ya
arkadaşlar
burada
eğer kod
doğru
düzgün bir
şekilde
yazılmazsa
sizin
birden fazla
thread
hani iyi niyetle
daha hızlı olsun
verim arsın
performans arsın
iyi niyetle
yazdığınız program
tam tersi
çok fazla
thread oluşturduğunuz için
daha fazla
kaynak tüketimine
neden olabilir
işte
race
condition
ya da
bu arada
race condition
da data race
aynı şey değil
arkadaşlar
arada şöyle bir
fark var
bunların hepsini
göreceksiniz ama
çok kısa bilgi vereyim
şimdi race
condition
birden fazla
thread'in
aynı
veriyi
kullanması
demek
ama bu
tanımsız
davranış
olabilir
ya da
olmayabilir
yani
birden fazla
thread'in
örneğin
aynı
değişkeni
örneğin
bir global
değişkeni
kullanması
eğer
bazı
önlemler
alınmazsa
tanımsız
davranış
durumu
oluşturabilir
işte ona
data race
deniyor
ama
o önlemler
alınsa da
programın
lojik yapısında
yanlışlıkları
olabilir
mesela
bir thread'in
daha önce
o veriye
erişmesi
başka bir thread'in
ondan sonra
o veriye
erişmesi
o işlem
yapıldıktan sonra
o veriye
erişmesi
gerekirken
eğer bu
sağlanmazsa
tanımsız
davranışı
olmasa da
programınızın
lojik yapısında
yanlışlıklar
hatalar
olabilir
yani program
istediğiniz gibi
çalışmayabilir
program görevini
yapmayabilir
işte az önce
bahsettiğim
deadlock
livelock
durumları
yani burada
bu
senkronizasyonu
sağlarken
yapılan
hatalar
thread'lerin
artık
ilerleyememesi
bloki
olarak kalması
sonucunu
doğurabilir
evet
hocam bu
önlemler
priority koşulları
veya mutex gibi
araçlar mı
oluyor
hemen söyleyeyim
evet arkadaşlar
burada
bu
data race
den kaçınmak
için
aslında
kullanılan
birden fazla
araç var
şimdi onu
uzun uzun
anlatmayayım
nasıl bunlar
alt başlığımız
olacak
ama tabi
en temel
araçlardan
bir tanesi
mutual
exclusion
yani
mutex
denilen
araçlar
arkadaşlar
mutex
burada
kast edilen ne
çok basit
şöyle bir
analoji verilir ya
efendim işte
bir tuvalet var
tuvalete girmek isteyen
birden fazla kişi var
ama tuvaletin
bir anahtarı var
o anahtarı
ele geçiren
tuvalete giriyor
kilitliyor
ve artık
oraya girmek isteyenler
kilitli olduğu için
beklemek zorunda kalıyor
ne zamanki
tuvaleti kullanan
tuvaletten
çıkıyor
anahtarı bırakıyor
o anahtarı
bekleyenlerden
biri
kapıyor
aslında bu daha güzel
anahtarı
çünkü bir sıra
olmak zorunda
değil
bu sefer
tuvalete
o giriyor
dolayısıyla
bu
mekanizmayla
birden fazla
thread'in
aynı veriyi
en az biri
yazma amaçlı
kullanması durumunda
bir problem olmuyor
ama
işte burada
mutex
tek araç
değil
bunun dışında
atomik
değişkenler
dediğimiz
özel değişkenlerin
kullanılması ki
standart kütüphane
bize bu konuda
destek veriyor
yani dilin
ve standart kütüphanenin
yiğit
bazı araçlarını
kullanarak
buradaki problemlerle
baş ediyoruz
ama
tabii en temel
araç seti
burada
kullanılan
mutexler
işte burada
neleri de
öğrenmek zorunda
kalacağız
bu mutex
sınıfları
aralarındaki
farklılıklar
neler
arkadaşlar
bunların
interfejsi
bütün bunları
öğrenmek durumunda
kalacağız
ve
başta da
söylediğim gibi
kodun
karmaşıklığı da
artıyor
yani
multi thread
kodla baş etmekle
single thread
kodla baş etmek
arkadaşlar
aynı zorluk
derecesinde
değil
yani benim
tabii kendi
ne diyelim
ölçümüm
multi thread
programlama
single thread
programlamaya göre
en az
3-4 kat
daha zor
çünkü
daha fazla
problemle
baş etmek
zorundasınız
ve arkadaşlar
bu
gerçekten
debug
sürecinde de
bazı hataları
bulmanız
kolay değil
efendim biz
neyse çok
uzatmadan
C++'ın
modern
C++'la
gelen
standart
kütüphanesine
değinelim
arkadaşlar şimdi
standart
kütüphanenin
bu
concurrency
bileşenleri
o kadar
fazla ki
yani
20-30 ders
sadece bunları
incelesek
yine zaman
yetmez
o yüzden
önce
en temel
bileşenlere
bakacağız
bu bileşenlerin
kullanımını
öğreneceğiz
ondan sonra
yavaş yavaş
detaya
ineceğiz
burada
önce şunu
söylemek
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
kütüphane
bu
multi thread
programlama
tarafında
ya da
paralel
programlama
tarafında
farklı farklı
seviyelerde
ayrı
araçlar
sunuyor
mesela
şöyle bir
anlatım
modeli
olabilirdi
ben sevmiyorum
mesela
YoCities'in
kitabında
böyle bir
yöntem
denemiş
pek başarılı
olduğumu da
düşünmüyorum
genelde çok
sevmeme rağmen
bu
YoCities'in
kitabını
standart
library
kitabını
orada
yüksek
seviyeden
alçak
seviyeye göre
anlatmış
ama
bu bence
iyi bir yol
değil
bence
tam tersi
burada
standart
kütüphanenin
öğelerini
öğrenirken
tam tersi
arkadaşlar
düşük
seviyeden
yüksek
seviyeye
doğru
gitmekte
ilerlemekte
fayda
var
efendim
burada
düşük
seviye
derken
olabilecek
en düşük
seviye
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
thread
sınıfını
kullanmak
thread
sınıfını
kullanmak
burada
standart
kütüphanemizin
thread
başlık
dosyasında
bir
yazılımsal
ve donanımsal
thread'i
temsil edebilecek
yani
nesneleri
bir
thread'i
temsil edecek
doğrudan
bir sınıf
var
bu sınıfın
ismi
herhalde
şaşırtıcı
olmaz
arkadaşlar
stud
thread
bu sınıfı
kullanmak
için
thread
başlık
dosyasını
include
edeceksiniz
ve bu
başlık
dosyasından
gelen
öğeleri
kullanabileceksiniz
bizde
işe
nereden
başlayacağız
thread
sınıfını
öğrenerek
başlayacağız
arkadaşlar
bu arada
şunu da
tabii
söyleyelim
diğer
birçok
araçta da
gördüğümüz
gibi
c++11
ile
gelen
araçlar
var
ama
diğer taraftan
c++14
standardıyla
eklenen
araçlar
da var
yani
bazı araçlar
örneğin
c++20
sınıfıyla
standardıyla
eklendi
yani
derleyicinizin
hangi
standardı
desteklediğine
bağlı olarak
bunları
kullanabilirsiniz
ya da
kullanamazsınız
ama ben
minimal
yine
mümkün olduğu
kadar
c++20
standardını
esas olarak
anlatacağım
arkadaşlar
thread
sınıfı
türünden
bir
nesne
oluşturabilirim
stutt
thread
şimdi
stutt
thread
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
bir thread'i
temsil ediyor
ama
arkadaşlar
tıklı bizim
stream nesnelerimiz
gibi
dosya nesnelerimiz
bu
henüz
herhangi bir
thread'i
çalıştırmamış
olabilir
benim
tabirim ne
bu
borçta
henüz kendisine
bir
iç yükü
yüklememiş
durumda
olabiliriz
default
construct edilmiş
bir thread
nesnesi
bu durumda
yani örneğin
ben böyle bir
nesne
tanımladığımda
bir thread
çalışmaya
başlıyor mu
cevap
hayır
zaten nasıl
çalışmaya
başlasın ki
bir thread'in
çalışması için
ona
bir
fonksiyon
callable
vermemiz
gerekiyor
yani burada
temel birim
bir
callable
bir thread
bir callable
kodlarını
yürütürken
başka bir
thread
callable
kodlarını
yürütebilir
ama
bir thread
nesnesi
bu şekilde
default
construct edilebilir
daha sonra
bu thread
nesnesine
bir
iş yükü
verebiliriz
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben
burada
iş yükü
terimini
kullanıyorum
ingilizce'de
kullanılan
terim
workload
ya da
bazı durumlarda
doğrudan
ask
özür dilerim
yani bu
işi
bu thread
yapsın
diyorsunuz ya
o
yapacağı
işin
kendisine
duruma göre
workload
ya da
ask
diyoruz
c++'ın
standart
yıkhanesinde
işte bu
task'in
ya da
workload'un
bir ne
olması gerekiyor
callable
olması
gerekiyor
peki
nasıl
callable'ı
vereceğiz
tipik yol
constructor
thread
sınıfının
template
constructor'ı
var
yani
thread
sınıfının
kendisi
template
değil
kendisi
jenerik bir sınıf
değil
zaten jenerik bir sınıf
olsaydı
bakın böyle
açısal parantezin
içine
neleri yazmamız
gerekirdi
template parametrelerine
karşılık gelen
template argümanlarını
yazmamız
gerekirdi
ama template
parametresi yok
çünkü sınıf
template değil
ama
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
constructor'ı
görüyorsunuz
template
sınıfın
default
constructörü
olmayan
parametreli
template
constructörü
birinci parametresine
her zaman
arkadaşlar
neyi alıyor
tahmin edin
çalıştırılacak
callable'ı
alıyor
fonksiyonun
birinci parametresinin
universal
referans
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
yani bu ne
demek
rvalue
ya da lvalue
value
kategorisinde
bir
expression
olarak
herhangi bir
callable'ı
bu
thread
nesnesinin
çalıştırmasını
talep ederek
ne yapabiliriz
argüman olarak
verebiliriz
bu kadar kolay
yani
aslında
başlangıç
seviyesi o kadar
kolay ki
mesela
şöyle bir
fonksiyon var
word funk
fonksiyonun ne
iş yaptığı
önemli değil
ben bu fonksiyonu
ana thread'in
değil de
İngilizce tabiriyle
oluşturulacak bir
child thread'in
çalıştırmasını
istersem
bir
thread nesnesi
oluşturuyorum
ve ona
fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
adresini
argüman olarak
veriyorum
ama
birazdan göreceğiz
burada
fonksiyon terimini
kullanmadım
dikkat ederseniz
callable terimini
kullandım
çünkü
burada
kodunu
çalıştırmanız
çalıştırmak
istediğiniz
callable
global bir
fonksiyon olabilir
bir sınıfın
member
fonksiyonu
olabilir
bir
function
pointer
değişkeni
argüman olarak
geçip
o function
pointer
değişkenin
tuttuğu
adresteki
fonksiyonun
thread tarafından
çalıştırılmasını
isteyebilirsiniz
bir
function
object vardır
bir
functor
class vardır
o
functor
class
türünden
nesneyi
thread
sınıfının
konstruktörüne
argüman olarak
geçip
sınıfın
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunun
thread tarafından
oluşturulan
çalıştırılmasını
sağlayabilirsiniz
şimdi burada
belki az önceki
açıklamam
yeterince
doyurucu
olmamış olabilir
özellikle konuyla
ilk tanışan
arkadaşlar için
arkadaşlar bakın
şimdi burada
maalesef
thread sözcüğünü
eğer
yeterince
nitelemezsek
hangi anlamda
kullandığımızı
konuşmacıyı
dinleyen
anlamayabilir
çünkü bakın
bir
işletim
sisteminin
threadinden
bahsediyoruz
mesela bu
thread
bu kodu
çalıştırıyor
cümlesinde
olduğu gibi
fakat bir de
standart kütüphanenin
thread türünden
nesnesinden
bahsediyoruz
soru
bizim kodda
herhangi bir noktada
gördüğümüz
bir thread
nesnesi
yani burada
örneğin
t isimli
nesne
donanımsal
bir
thread'e
karşılık
gelmek
zorunda mı
hayır
henüz
ona bir
thread
assign edilmemiş
olabilir
ya da
şu da
olabilir
bir thread
ona bağlanmıştır
ama
o thread
o kolbalın
kodunu
tamamen
çalıştırmıştır
çalışması
bitince
bizim
thread'imiz
tekrar
tabiri caizse
boşa çıkmış
olabilir
işte arkadaşlar
bunu
sınamak
içinde
standart
kütüphanenin
thread sınıfı
bize
bir fonksiyon
veriyor
yani
örneğin
thread sınıfının
bahsettiğim
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
joinable
isimli bir
fonksiyonu
var
joinable
fonksiyonu
bize
bool değer
döndürüyor
thread'in
joinable
olması
demek
thread
nesnesine
gerçekten
çalıştıracağı
bir kod
vermişiz
ve o kod
halen
thread'i
çalıştırıyor
yani
o thread'in
işi
bitmemiş
o fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
henüz
sonlanmamışsa
o zaman
joinable
fonksiyonu
bize
arkadaşlar
true
değer verecek
neden
bu fonksiyonun
ismi
joinable
çünkü
bir thread'e
bir iş yükü
verdikten sonra
tanımsız
davranış
olmaması
için
ya da
arkadaşlar
programın
duruma göre
sonlandırılmaması
için
terminate
fonksiyonuyla
sonlandırılmaması
için
sınıfın
join
ya da
detach
isimli
iki fonksiyonundan
birini çağırmamız
gerekiyor
ama oraya
daha yolumuz
var
mesela
arkadaşlar
stu
see out
iostream
şimdilik
using
direktifini
kullanacağım
evet
bakın şimdi
see out
k'nin
joinable'ı
crew değer mi
verecek
false mu
değer verecek
cevap
tabi ki
false değer
verecek
çünkü
buna
atanmış
assign edilmiş
bir thread
şu anda
söz konusu
değil
ama bakın
buna bir iş yükü
verseydim
o iş yükünü
çalıştırsaydı
arkadaşlar
ve o
çalıştırma
sonuçlansaydı
bitseydi
ondan sonra
joinable
fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
yine false
değer verecekti
ama iş yükü
verdiğim zaman
onun çalışması
devam ediyorsa
ya da en azından
ben bundan
emin değilsem
o zaman
true değer verecek
programı
değerleyip
çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
bakın
standart
output'a
sıfır yazdı
yani
false değer
yazdı
şu anda
bool alfa state'inde
olmadığı için
false yazmadı
sıfır
yazdı
arkadaşlar
ama şimdi
bakın
şimdi
ben
constructor'a
örneğin
iş yükü
olarak
fan fonksiyonunu
versem
ne oluyor
bu noktada
aslında
arka planda
işletim sisteminin
kodları
çalışıyor
ve thread
oluşturuluyor
yani donanımsal
anlamda thread
oluşturuluyor
ve bu
fonksiyonu
ikinci bir
thread olarak
main thread'den
ayrı bir
chart thread
olarak
bu fonksiyonun
kodunu
çalıştırmaya
başlıyor
yani programın
akışı
bu noktadayken
17. satıra
koyduğum
yorum satırına
bakın
şu anda
arka planda
iki tane
ayrı thread
koşuyor
birinci
koşan
thread
işte bizim
programımızın
ana thread'i
ona main thread
deniyor
ikincisi de
fung fonksiyonunun
kodu
çalışıyor
işte bizim
arkadaşlar
bu
fung fonksiyonunun
kodunun
çalışmasını
sonlandırmak
için
eğer sonlanmamışsa
sonlandırmak
için
yani
thread sınıfı
türünden
nesnenin
o iş yükünü
çalıştırıp
tamamladığını
tamamlama garantisini
sağlamak için
sınıfın
join fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
join fonksiyonunun
çağrıldığı
noktada
artık
join fonksiyonunu
çağıran
thread
bloke oluyor
ve
bu
t
isimli
nesnenin
arkadaşlar
çalıştırdığı
fonksiyonunun
kodu
sonuna kadar
çalıştırılıyor
yani
artık
join fonksiyonundan
sonra
neden eminiz
artık
bizim
colable'ımızın
çalıştırılması
sona erdi
bu arada
bir yanlış
anlamı
olmasın
bu arada
tabii ki
daha
ben
join fonksiyonuna
gelmeden
zaten
burada
o kodun
çalıştırılması
sonlanmış
olabilir
ama
ondan emin
olamam
orada
deterministlik
bir yapı yok
benim
artık
ondan emin
olmam için
join fonksiyonunu
ya da
birazdan
göreceğimiz
detach
isimli
fonksiyonu
çağırmam
gerekiyor
thread
kullanırken
joinable
ise
join yap
mı
demeliyiz
arkadaşlar
normalde
sorunun
cevabı
evet
birazdan
geleceğiz
çok yavaş
gidiyorum
merak etmeyin
bunların
hepsini
anlatacağım
ama
siz zaten
joinable
olduğundan
eminseniz
böyle bir
kontrol
yapmanıza
gerek yok
ama
işin içine
taşıma
semantiği
girdiği zaman
ve
bazı
başka
konular
girdiği zaman
bundan
emin olmadığınız
durumlar
olabilir
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
en önemli
noktalardan biri
şu
eğer ben
bir thread
nesnesine
bir
callable
verip
o iş yükünü
çalıştırmasını
talep ettikten
sonra
arkadaşlar
biraz
sabırlı
olursanız
hemen
bütün sorularınızın
cevabını
şimdi alacaksınız
o yüzden
hemen doğrudan
sorularınıza
cevap
vermeyi
pek tercih etmiyorum
ama
Alihan'a da
cevap vereyim
Alihan diyor ki
programın akışı
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
ana thread
burada
bloki olacak
yani bakın
şurada
bir kod
yazsaydım
mesela burada
herhangi bir
kod var
P
thread'inin
P isimli
değişkene
bağlanmış
thread'in
çalıştırdığı
kodun
çalışması
bitmedikçe
programın
akışının
buraya gelme
ihtimali yok
Alihan bunu
kastediyorsunuz
değil mi
ama bakın
join fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
eğer zaten
çalışma bitmişse
hemen buraya
geçecek
çalışma
bitmeyecek
bitmemişse
burada
ana thread
bloki olacak
önce
efendim
bu örnekte
funk'ın
çalışması
sonlanacak
diğer thread'in
funk'ın
çalıştırması
sonlanacak
ondan sonra
programın
akışı
buraya gelecek
yani
join fonksiyonunu
çağırmamız
çağıran
thread'in
bloke edilmesini
yani onun
çalışmasının
durdurulmasını
sağlıyor
ama zaten
eğer bu noktaya
gelene kadar
farm fonksiyonunun
kodunun
çalışması
bitmişse
join'in yürütülmesi
doğrudan
programın
akışı
buraya gelecek
yani
join demek
bu thread'in
çalışması
iş yükünü
çalıştırması
bitene kadar
bekleyecek
burada demek
yani böyle bir
soyutlama
yapmalısınız
Alihan anlaşıldı
mı
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakınız
ama asıl
problemlerden
bir tanesi şu
eğer bir
thread'e
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
bir iş yükü
verirsem
ama
thread nesnesinin
thread sınıfının
join ya da
detach fonksiyonlarından
birini
çağırmazsam
bu da şu
demek
thread
aslında
teknik
tabiriyle
thread
joinable
state'deyken
destructor
çağrılırsa
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
yani
bizim
thread nesnesinin
destructor'ı
çağrıldığında
söz konusu
thread'in
joinable
olduğundan
artık
joinable
olmadığından
ters söyledim
emin olmamız
gerekiyor
mesela
şu anda
joinable
state'de mi
evet
peki
destructor
burada çağrılırsa
ne olur
işte
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılır
yani
destructor
çağrıldığında
bizim
thread'imizin
joinable
state'de
demin
dil soruşması
olduğu tam
tersini
söyledim
joinable
state'de
olmaması
gerekiyor
hemen
bunu bir göstermek
istiyorum
bakınız
arkadaşlar
şimdi
necati ne
gösterdin ki
diyebilirsiniz
burada
aslında
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
terminate
fonksiyonu
da
abort
fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
ve program
abort
fonksiyonunun
kodunun
çalıştırılmasıyla
sona erdi
bazı örneklerde
ben bunu
daha iyi
gösterebilmek
için
bakın
my
terminate
isimli
bir fonksiyon
yazacağım
yani
abortun
çağrıldığını
daha iyi
görün diye
ve bu
fonksiyonun
içinde
bu fonksiyonun
çağrıldığını
gösteren
bir yazı
yazdıracağım
my
terminate
hold
ve
ondan sonra
ben
abortu ya da
exit'i
çağıracağım
ve
tabi
daha önce
kredilere
başlatmadan önce
arkadaşlar
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
bunları
set terminate
fonksiyonuyla
terminate'in
çağrıca
fonksiyonu
kayıt edeceğim
değiştireceğim
ve
my
terminate'in
adresini
vereceğim
böyle kod
yazdığım durumlarda
siz bunu
neden
yazdığımı
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
yani
abortun
çağrıldığını
size
göstermek için
diyor ki
Deniz Akkuş
şans esere
terminate
çağrılmayabilir
tabi ki
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burada
deterministik
bir yapı yok
yani
örneğin
main threat
daha önce de
sonlanabilir
değil mi
evet
o yüzden
bazı örneklerde
de
mesela burada
zaman
kaybetmesi
için
her örnekte
tek tek
açıklamayayım
zaman
kaybetmesi
için
burada
iş yükünde
arkadaşlar
ilgili
thread'i
belirli süre
bloke edecek
bir çağrı da
yapacağım
onların hepsini
yavaş yavaş
göstereceğim size
bunların hepsi
ilerleyen saatlerde
öğreneceğimiz
öğeler
mesela
stud
this thread'in
arkadaşlar
neden
krono kütüphanesini
başta anlattığımı da
şimdi daha iyi
göreceksiniz
sleep for
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
buradaki
kod çalıştırıldığında
bu noktada
birerli bir süre
beklemesini
bloke edilmesini
sağlayabilirim
mesela
using
arkadaşlar
stud
krono
using
name
krono
mesela burada
5 saniye
beklemesini
ya da
milisaniye
mikrosaniye
ne kadar
istersem
beklemesini
sağlayabilirim
örneğin
milisaniye
evet
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
my terminate
çağırıldı
de
abort
fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
şimdi
birbiri sırayla
gidelim ki
konu zaten
çok karmaşık
ve çok fazla
öğe var
ben
biraz anlatayım
siz yine
sorularınızı
yazın
ama hemen
sorularınıza
cevap
beklemeyin
şimdilik
burada üstünde
durduğum
ilk nokta şu
eğer bir
thread
nesnesi
hayattaysa
ve onun
destructor'ı
çağrılmışsa
çağrıldığında
thread
joinable
durumdaysa
yani
arkadaşlar
join
fonksiyonu
joinable
true
değer veriyorsa
o zaman
terminate
çağrılıyor
yani
bu da ne
demek
sizin
programınızın
sonlanmaması
için
thread
sınıfının
sınıf
nesnesinin
destrakt
edildiğinde
destroy
artık
daha önce
join
ya da
detach
fonksiyonlarından
birini
çağırmış
olmanız
gerekiyor
bu garanti
vermeniz
gerekiyor
şimdi burada
ben olsam
muhakkak
sizin de
aklınıza
bu
gelirdi
ilk sorum
çoğulurdu
değil mi
burada düzgün
soru ne
ya
Necati
kursun
başından
beri
şu
meşhur
rayi
idiomunu
kullanıyoruz
rayi
idiomunu
ne olduğunu
tekrar
anlatmayacağım
yani
konstruktörün
tipik olarak
kaynağı
edilmesi
ve destraktörün
kaynağı
geri vermesi
rayinin
en çok
gerektiği
yer
derden
biri
burası
değil mi
o zaman
şöyle
olsaydı ya
thread
sınıfı
destraktörü
çağrıldığında
arkadaşlar
destraktör
kendisi
join
fonksiyonunu
eğer
çağrılmamışsa
çağırsaydı
böylece böyle
bir problem
olmasaydı
gerçekten de
böyle olması
daha iyiydi
ama
başlangıçta
belki
biraz acele
edildiğinden
belki biraz
tasarım
hatası
olduğu
söylenebilir
belki biraz da
bazı konularda
avantaj
sağlamak için
böyle yapılmış
olabilir
ama daha sonra
işte
Oğuzhan Bey'in
söylediği
J-thread sınıfı
direklendi
J-thread sınıfını
ayrıca
anlatacağım
ama J-thread
aslında
özünde bir
rayı
sarmalayıcısı
yani ben
thread sınıfı
türünden bir
nesne yerine
J-thread sınıfı
türünden bir
nesneyi
kullanırsam
o aslında
bir thread
nesnesini
sarmalıyor
ama
J-thread'in
destraktörü
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
efendim
joinable
durumdaysa
önce
join fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
ama
demişler ki
J-thread sınıfını
anlattığımda
göreceksiniz
ama demişler ki
madem
geç kaldık
böyle bir
rayı sınıfını
sonradan
ekledik
bari buna
ilave bir özellik
de katalım
demişler
işte J-thread
sınıfını
sınıf nesnesini
kullanarak
çalışan thread'in
sonlandırılması
özelliğini de
eklemişler
yani burada
biraz akılları
sonra
başlarına gelmiş
diyebiliriz
arkadaşlar
evet
yavaş yavaş
gidiyorum
thread sınıfının
join fonksiyonunun
ne yaptığından
bahsettik
örnekler vereceğiz
ama
bir tane daha
önemli fonksiyonu var
bizim
bir başka
seçeneğimiz
daha var
o da
arkadaşlar
thread sınıfının
detach fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
biliyorsunuz
detach
ayırmak
demek
değil mi
bir şeyi
bir yerden
ayırmak
thread sınıfının
detach fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
tabi ki
bunun üstünde de
uzun uzun duracağız
detach'i
çağırırken
çok dikkatli
olmamız gerekiyor
artık
ne
talep etmiş
oluyorsunuz
bu geri
planda
çalışsın
artık
bana bağlı
değil
yani bu
arka
planda
işini bitirene
kadar
çalışsın
arkadaşlar
yalnız
tabi ki
detach fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde
çağırdığınız zaman
neleri de
hesaplamanız
gerekiyor
az önce
bir arkadaşım
demişti ya
deniz mi
söylemişti
main thread
sona erdiğinde
artık onun
çalışması da
bitecek
yani
onun
o arka
plandaki
işi
yapıp
bitirdiğinden
emin olduktan
sonra
main thread'in
sonlanması
gerekiyor
o zaman
join
ya bunun
çalışması
bitmemişse
bitsin
efendim
bunu
oluşturan
thread
bloki
olsun
ya da
detach
fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
detach
fonksiyonu
arka
planda
bu
çalışsın
artık
o
adeta
benim
çocuğum
değil
o
benden
bağımsız
detach
oldu
ayrıldı
bu iki
seçenekten
birini
kullanacaksınız
eğer
join
ya da
detach
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
artık
thread
joinable
olmaktan
arkadaşlar
çıkacak
ve
destructor
çağrıldığında
bir problem
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılmayacak
evet
ama destructor
çağrıldığında
eğer
daha önce
detach
ya da
join
fonksiyonu
çağrılmamışsa
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
ama
şimdi
ben sırasıyla
şunları
anlatmak istiyorum
sizin beklediğiniz
sıranın
biraz dışında
olabilir
onu
bana
bırakacaksınız
eğer
gerçekten
müsaade ederseniz
ben kendi
sıramla
anlatmak istiyorum
arkadaşlar
önce
threadlere
bu
solubulların
verilmesi
threadlerin
iş yükünü
alması
çünkü burada
birçok
farklı durum
olabilir
global bir
fonksiyon olabilir
bir member
bir sınıfın
statik ya da
non-statik
üye fonksiyonu
olabilir
bir function
object
nesnesi
olabilir
efendim
bir lambda
ifadesinden
oluşturulmuş
bir closure
object
olabilir
bunların
hepsini
thread'e
iş yükü
olarak
verebilirsiniz
word load
olarak
verebilirsiniz
ama
ikinci bir
nokta var
hemen yine
konuşmamız
gereken
daha konunun
ilk başlarında
konuşmamız
gereken
az önce
benim verdiğim
örnekte
başlangıçta
birçok örnekte
böyle olacak
iş yükü
olarak
verdiğim
fun fonksiyonunun
parametre
değişkeni
ya da
değişkenleri
yoktu
peki
fun fonksiyonunun
bir ya da
birden fazla
parametre
değişkeni
olsaydı
o zaman
o thread'in
çalıştırılma
sırasında
o parametrelere
de argüman
geçilmesi
gerekecekti
o zaman
bu argümanları
tahmin edebileceğiniz
gibi
biz yine
thread sınıfının
constructor'ına
göndereceğiz
ve
constructor yine
perfect forwarding
mekanizmasıyla
bunu
arkadaşlar
bir şekilde
çalıştırılacak
iş yükü olan
kolabalın
parametrelerine
geçilecek
bunun nasıl yapılacağını
göreceğiz ki
burada
bazı problemlerin
olmasını
garanti altına
almak için
referans
semantiğine
dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor
ve bazı yerlerde
reference
wrapper
sınıfını
kullanmamız
gerekiyor
yine
konuşmamız
gereken
bir başka
önemli nokta
exception
handling
peki ya
örneğin
func fonksiyonu
çalışırken
func fonksiyonunun
kodu
bir exception
gönderirse
ne olacak
yani ben
örneğin
burada
thread nesnesini
oluşturduğum yerde
bu exception'i
doğrudan
yakalayabilir miyim
şimdilik kısa cevap
hayır
eğer
wordload'dan
bir exception
throw edilirse
o exception
o wordload
çalışan kod
tarafından
yakalanmazsa
propagate ederse
yani dışarı çıkarsa
doğrudan
yine
arkadaşlar
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
dolayısıyla
işte işi zorlaştıran
noktalardan
biri de
sizin
çalıştırdığınız
kolabalın
arkadaşlar
bir exception
throw etmesi
durumunda
o exception'da
da başa
çıkmanız
gerekiyor
yani o
exception'i
ya yakalayacaksınız
çünkü yakalamazsanız
kod içinde
o dışarı çıkarsa
İngilizcesi
propagate
ederse
ya da
emit
ederse
doğrudan
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
ondan sonra
ben anlatacağım
sırayı
anlatıyorum
thread sınıfının
üye fonksiyonlarını
göreceğiz
taşıma
semantiğinden
bahsedeceğiz
kursun başlarında
örnek olarak
vermiştim
ama detaylı
anlatmadım
tabi thread
sınıfına
daha yeni
geliyoruz
arkadaşlar
thread sınıfı
tipik bir
move only type
yani
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
taşımaya
açık
yani
copy
constructor'ı
ve copy
assignment
fonksiyonları
delete edilmiş
ama
move
constructor
ve move
assignment
var
arkadaşlar
bu da şimdi
taşıma
semantiğine
çok güzel
bir örnek
ben move
only type'lardan
bahsederken
demiştim ki
ya dedim
kopyalamanın
mantıksal bir
karşılığı yok
ya da
kopyalama
bilinçli olarak
sınıfın
tasarımında
asla kopyalansa da
olur ama
kopyalama
istenmemiş de
olabilir
mesela burada
bir thread'in
kopyalanması ne
olabilirdi ki
ne anlama
gelebilir
bir thread
zaten
nesnesi
arkadaşlar
çalıştırılacak
ayrı bir
akış
demek
nasıl onun
kopyasını
çıkartayım
o akışın
bir kopyasını
çıkartmak
zaten
mantıksal
olarak
mümkün
değil
o yüzden
thread sınıfı
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
ama taşımaya
karşı
açık
taşımaya
karşı açık
olması çok
önemli
mesela bir
fonksiyon
bir thread'i
çalıştırırken
o thread'in
başka bir
fonksiyona
o thread
nesnesinin
başka bir
fonksiyona
taşınmasını
sağlayabilir
yani artık
o thread'in
akışından
bir başka
fonksiyon
sorumlu
hale
gelebilir
işte burada
taşıma
semantiğinden
de
bahsetmemiz
gerekiyor
o zaman
bugün
hepsini
tabi
görmemiz
mümkün
olmayacak
ama
en azından
hedef olarak
şunu koyalım
thread sınıfının
konstruktörü
gönderecek
argümanlar
arkadaşlar
callable
farklı farklı
callable'lar
nasıl geçiliyor
buradaki tipik
problemler
neler
bunlardan
bahsedeceğiz
ondan sonra
diğer
üye fonksiyonları
göreceğiz
this thread
isimli bir
namespace var
arkadaşlar
bu namespacede
3-4 tane
fonksiyon var
ikisini gördüğünüz
sleep
for
until
get
id
gibi
arkadaşlar
ve yield
fonksiyonları
var
aslında
hepsini de
saymış
oldum
bu fonksiyonlar
nedir
ne işe yarar
bunları da
göreceğiz
thread sınıfıyla
ilgili
ancak
thread sınıfını
gördükten sonra
burayı bitirdikten
sonra
yavaş yavaş
senkronizasyon
nedir
data race
efendim
ile nasıl
mücadele
ediyoruz
mutex
sınıfları
neler
lock
sınıfları
neler
onları
yavaş yavaş
göreceğiz
ama burada
hemen bir şeyin
dikkatinizi çekmiş
olması gerekiyor
çekti mi bilmiyorum
ama ilk defa
tanışanların
arkadaşlar
thread sınıfını
bu şekilde
doğrudan
kullanarak
eğer
fonksiyon
örneğin bir
geri dönüş
değeri varsa
fonksiyonun
a
geri dönüş
değeri
zaten
varlık
nedeni
olabilir
yani
çalıştırdığım
iş yükü
bir değeri
hesaplamaya
yönelik
olabilir
ve
hayır bir iş
yapıyordur da
ama
o thread'i
oluşturan
o iş
yapıldıktan sonra
fonksiyonun
oluşturacağı
geri dönüş
değerini de
kullanmak
isteyebilir
peki o
geri dönüş
değerini
nasıl
kullanacağız
thread sınıfı
doğrudan
bu olanağa
vermiyor
maalesef
yani
fonksiyonun
üreteceği
onu
oluşturan
thread'e
ileteceği
değer ya da
değerler varsa
onun için
yine
dilin
ya da
kütüphanenin
başka araçlarını
kullanmak
zorundayız
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şöyle bir şey
yapalım
izleyin
önce
en basit
senaryoyu
bir kez daha
gösterelim
see out
punk
bu fonksiyonun
gerçekten çalıştırıldığını
görelim
bu thread
necati
aynı zamanda
birden fazla
thread nesnesi
oluşturabilir miyim
tabii ki
onları da
göreceğiz
yani
başlangıçtaki
örneklerde
hep
ana thread
main thread
bir tane
child thread
oluşturuyor
sanki hep böyle
olması gerektiğini
ilk defa tanışan
arkadaşlar
düşünmesin
mesela
yirmi tane
elli tane
yüz tane
iyi
ya da kötü
anlamında
söylemiyorum
ayrı thread
oluşturup
bunları bir dizide
thread nesnelerin
bir dizide
ya da bir
konteynerda
tutabilirim
yani
on tane
thread oluşturup
onların
ayrı ayrı
kodları
çalıştırmasını
sağlayabilirim
tabii burada
bu konuları
anlatırken
başlangıçta hiçbir zaman
endişemiz ne değil
efendim bu kadar
thread oluşturmak
iyi mi
astarı yüzünden
pahalıya mı
çıkar
vesaire
bu sorular
şimdilik bizim
ilgi alanımızda
değil
thread
t
funk
necati böyle yazmakla
böyle yazmak arasında
bir fark var mı
hiçbir fark yok
yine function
to
pointer
conversion
söz konusu
ve
t'nin
join
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
ama buraya
bir kod daha
koyuyorum
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
main thread'in
daha önce çalışıp
bitme
şansı var mı
yok
çünkü programın
akışı
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
burada zaten
blokü olacak
ama ben
birçok kodda
arka planda
ne oluyor
onu da
görmenizi
sağlamak için
şöyle bir
kod yazacağım
main
is
artık ingilizce ya da
türçe
still
running
arkadaşlar
başlangıçta çok uyarı
yapıyorum
çünkü çok uzun sürecek
konu
bunu da baştan
söyleyeyim
bazı örneklerde
bu siyahat da bir
sınıf nesnesi
değil mi
üstelik global
bir sınıf nesnesi
dolayısıyla
siyahat nesnesi de
yine az önce
biraz açıkladığımız
data racing
konusu
olabilir
değil mi
yani
bir thread
siyahat nesnesini
kullanırken
başka bir thread de
onu
kullanma durumuna
girebilir
bu durumda
yine
eğer önlem
alınmazsa
bazı problemler
olabilir
işte ben
bazı
kodlarda
sizin odak noktanızı
oraya yönlendirmemek
için
siyahat nesnesini
doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
c++20
standardıyla
gelen
arkadaşlar
syncstream
isimli bir
başlık dosyası
var
orada
o syncstream
isimli
yalnız bu
c++20
sınıfı
kullanacağım
o sınıf
türünden
bir nesnenin
konstruktörüne
ben
siyahat'ı
argüman olarak
verirsem
o arka planda
senkronizasyonu
kendisi
halledecek
aksi halde
örneklerde
karşınıza
çıkacak
bir şekilde
siyahat nesnesine
birden fazla
thread'in
ulaşması
onu
kullanması
söz konusuysa
onu da
data race'e
karşı korumak için
örneğin bir
mutex
kullanmak
zorundayım
ama en azından
şu garanti var
arkadaşlar
siyahat nesnesine
birden fazla
thread kullandığı
zaman
en kötü
ihtimalle
başınıza
gelebilecek
olan
karakter bazında
ayrı ayrı
yazması
o stream nesneleri
bu açıdan
güvenli
ama mesela
şöyle bir duruma
ulaşabilir mi
eğer bir önlem
almazsak
mesela
bir thread'in
çalıştırdığı
kodda
efendim
Ahmet
Bayraktar
yazı
yazılacak
streame
ama
başka bir
thread'te
yine
arkadaşlar
birlikte
concurrent olarak
çalıştırman
başka bir
thread'te
o da
arkadaşlar
efendim
Süleyman
Ersin
bu yazıyı
yazdıracak
şimdi şöyle bir
garanti var mı
bir önlem
alınmazsa
bunlardan bir
tanesi
önce yazılacak
Ahmet
Bayraktar
ondan sonra
Süleyman
Ersin
arkadaşlar
yazdırılacak
yani ben
ya Ahmet
Bayraktar
yazısını daha
önce
ya da
Süleyman
Ersin
yazısını daha
önce
göreceğim
böyle olabilir
ama böyle
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela şöyle bir
durum oluşabilir mi
önlem
almazsam
Ahmet
Bayraktar'ın
ahını
yazdı
ondan sonra
Süleyman'ın
sulu yazdı
sonra Ahmet
Bayraktar'ın
netini yazdı
böyle bir durum
oluşabilir mi
oluşabilir
ama en azından
burada
ilerleyen
dakikalarda da
anlatacağım
bir tanımsız
davranış
durumu
söz konusu
olmayacak
o yüzden
bu
O-Sync Stream
sınıfını
kullandığım yerde
ya da
kullanacağım
yerlerde
odak noktanız
O-Sync Stream
olmasın
orada tek amaç
C-Out
nesnesini
doğrudan
kullandığım zaman
arkadaşlar
senkronizasyon
olmadığı için
bu
standart
altkota yazılan
yazılar
birbiri içine
geçmiş
olabilir
bu arada
en önemli
noktalardan
birini de
söyleyelim
burası
belki
başta
söylemem
gereken
bir noktaydı
birçok
arkadaşım
zaten
bildiği için
belki
söylemem
gerekmedi
ama ilk
defa
tanışanlar
için
söylemem
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
birden fazla
thread
çalıştığı zaman
sadece
main thread
ve
bir tane
chart thread
olsa dahi
oradaki
kodların
yani
main thread
kodların
çalıştırılma
sırası
hiçbir şekilde
deterministik
değil
yani
şöyle
diyebilir
miyiz
diyelim ki
iki tane
fonksiyon
var
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyonu
ve bar fonksiyonu
burası
önemli
bu fonksiyonu
ve bar fonksiyonun
içinde
statementlar
var
statement 1
statement 2
statement 3
statement 4
ve
full fonksiyonun
içinde de
statementlar
var
derleyicinin
en azından
bu
statementlarla
ilgili bir
optimizasyon
yapmadığını
düşünelim
ama şunu
vurgulamak
istiyorum
burada
şöyle bir şey
var mı
iki thread
threadlerden biri
barı çalıştırıyor
full'yu çalıştırıyor
şöyle bir şey
var mı
barın bütün
statementları
bitecek
ondan sonra
full'un bütün
statementları
çalıştırılacak
ya da tam tersi
ya da şöyle
olabilir mi
örneğin
barda
statement 1
çalıştırıldı
ama
o arada
full'da da
statement 1
çalıştırıldı
sonra bu
çalıştı
bunun hiçbir
şekilde
eğer siz
bunu belirleyecek
bir
araç
kullanmazsanız
hiçbir şekilde
ne değil
arkadaşlar
deterministik
değil
orayı anladık mı
evet
şimdi neyse
biz yavaş yavaş
gidelim
acele etmeyelim
kavramlarda
birbirine karışmazsan
ilk olarak
şu kodu
çalıştırarak
başlayalım
evet bakın
funk çalıştı
main is
still running
buraya geldiğinde
blok oldu
şimdi örnekleri
biraz zenginleştirelim
mesela
arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar bakın
pan fonksiyonu
içinde
bu örnek özellikle
çok önemli
pan fonksiyonu
içinde
efendim
bir tane
döngü deyimi
olsun
bu
full fonksiyonu
olsun
bu döngü
deyimi
bin kez
dönen bir
döngü olsun
arkadaşlar
ve
to see out
efendim put
standart output'a
bir tane
nokta karakteri
yazsın
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
efendim
ikinci bir fonksiyonu
olsun
bu fonksiyonun
ismi de
bar fonksiyonu
olsun
biraz daha
arttırayım
bin yerine
örneğin
on bin
yapayım
bu da
on bin kez
dönsün
burada da
nokta
yerine
örneğin
yıldız
karakteri
olsun
bir tane
daha
fonksiyonumuz
olsun
bunun ismi de
bas fonksiyonu
olsun
burada da
artı
karakteri
bassın
şimdi yavaş yavaş
sorularıma cevap
vermeye çalışın
soru
ben örneğin
ana thread
içinde
foo'yu
barı
bazı
ayrı
çarp threadlerde
çalıştırabilir miyim
cevap
tabii ki
bunun için
nasıl bir kod
yazmam gerekir
son derece
basit
üç tane ayrı
thread nesnesi
oluşturacağım
şimdilik
c thread'i
yok farz ediyorum
thread
arkadaşlar
p1
foo
thread
t2
efendim bar
thread t3
bas
şimdi programın akışı
bu noktaya gelmeyinde
ben
üç nesnede
konstrakt edilmiş durumda
şimdi sorularıma cevap
vermeye çalışıyorum
bence bunlar çok önemli
bir
ben
ilk statement olarak
t1'i
konstrakt edecek
kodu yazdığım için
bu program
devamını yazacağım
tabii çalıştırıldığında
kesinlikle
ekrana
önce nokta
karakteri yazılır
yani ilk yazılan
karakterin nokta
olması garanti
altındadır
doğru mu
cevap
tabii ki
hayır
işte bakın
deterministik değil
derken
Necati niye
hayır ki
o daha önce
çalışmıyor mu
arkadaşlar
arka planda
çok şey
gizleniyor
işletim sisteminde
o çalıştırılacak
bu threadleri
oluşturmak için
çalıştırılacak
kodlar vesaire
var
hiçbir şekilde
deterministik
değil
yani örneğin
şunların hepsi
düşük ya da yüksek
ihtimal dahilinde
mesela şöyle bir şey
olabilir mi
önce
10 bin tane
nokta yazdı
efendim
ondan sonra
10 bin tane
yıldız
sonra 10 bin tane
artı
olabilir
burada sayının
ne olduğuna bağlı olarak
belki çok düşük
bir ihtimal dersiniz
şöyle böyle dersiniz
ama olabilir
şöyle olabilir mi
önce 10 bin tane
yıldız
sonra 10 bin tane
artı
bunu
az
specified
diyebilir miyiz
diyebiliriz
deterministik
değil
peki şöyle
olabilir mi
Resul
mesela
10 tane
nokta yazdı
sonra 4 tane
yıldız yazdı
sonra 20 tane
artı yazdı
böyle olabilir mi
olabilir
yani burada
kesinlikle
deterministik
bir yapı
beklemeyin
bunu şunun için
söylüyorum
sizin beklediğiniz gibi
çalışmasını
dibag ederken
bir garanti
zannedip
ona göre
bir lojik
yapı
oluşturursanız
o doğru değil
şimdi benim
üçünü de
detach etmem
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
izleyin
p1
detach diyorum
özür dün
join etmem
gerekiyor
join
p2
p3
join
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdiden
şunu da
söyleyelim
eğer
daha sonra
göreceğimiz
jthread
sınıfını
kullanıyor
olsaydık
yani bu
sınıf
nesneleri
thread değil de
jthread
olsaydı
aslında
kodda
fazla bir değişiklik
hatta bu
kodda
hiçbir değişiklik
yapmayacaktık
sadece
ne olacaktı
jthread
nesnesi
yani
t1
t2
t3
destroy
olduğunda
eğer
joinable
durumdaysa
arkadaşlar
önce
join
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaktı
yani
rayı
implemente
eden
sınıf
maalesef
stu
thread
sınıfı
değil
jthread
sınıfı
orayı anladık mı
ama
ben birerli bir noktaya
kadar
sanki
jthread
hiç yokmuş
gibi davranacağım
anlatacağım
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
noktalar
yıldızlar
artılar
mesela
programı
tekrar
çalıştırsam
Resul
aynı çıktığı
alma garantim
var mı
kesinlikle
yok
mesela sayıyı
biraz azaltayım
arkadaşlar
100 yaptım
izleyin
hatta şöyle diyelim
bari
buraları
anlamak önemli
constexper
int n
efendim
bakın
burada
n'i
kullanayım
hocam
program bittiğinde
tamamlanmış
oluyor mu
en azından
kesinlikle
program bittiğinde
tamamlanmış
oluyor mu
derken
join ederseniz
tabi ki
eğer join
etmezseniz
arkadaşlar
o
anlattım
ne olduğunu
evet
bakın
şimdi
mesela
burada
gerçekten
daha
100 tane
yazmadan
önce
yıldız
yazdı
buraya kadar
artıları
yazdı
iyice
azaltayım
mesela
burada
büyük ihtimal
ne
tabi
bu
benim
beklentim
tanesini
sırayla
tamamlayacak
artık
çok az
olduğu için
büyük
ihtimalle
evet
bakın
gerçekten
yine de
olmadı
nokta
yıldız
burada anlatmak
istediğimin
ne olduğu
açık
deterministik
değil
eğer
deterministik
olmasını
istiyorsanız
onu garanti
altına
alacak
bir kod
yazmalısınız
onlara
sonra geleceğiz
ama şimdi
ilk konu
başlığımız
neydi
polubullar
neler olabilir
argümanlar
nasıl
geçilir
bunları
konuşacaktık
arkadaşlar
çok tipik
durumlardan
bir tanesi
lambda
ifadesinden
oluşturulacak
lambda
fonksiyonun
thread tarafından
çalıştırılması
işte
thread sınıfının
konstruktörünün
template olması
bu olanağı
veriyor
mesela
auto
f
eşittir
arkadaşlar
see out
evet
merhaba
dünya
çok klasik oldu
ama
evet
bir tane
function
objekti
oluşturdum
bunu
doğrudan
stukkred
p
argüman olarak
verebilirim
f
ve
p'nin
join'i
öyle
de
yazsam
olurdu
evet
bir yerde
bir parantez
hatası var
m
ve
d
f
arkadaşlar
küme parantezi
olmak zorunda
değil
hata
şurada
noktalı örgül
yok
hatırlayın
hayır hayır
Resul
küme
parametre parantezi
olmak zorunda
değil
Cengiz Han'ın
söylediği yerde
hata
noktalı örgül
burada
hatırlayın
eğer parametre
değişkeni yoksa
o parametre
parantezini
yazmak zorunda
değilim
ben yanlışlıkla
ne yapmışım
bu noktalı örgülü
yazının içine
koymuşum
problem orada
evet
bravo
Cengiz Han Bey
evet bakın
Necate Bey şöyle
yazabilir miydim
lambda ifadesi zaten
bir
PR value expression
ama bir
geçe nesneye
karşılık gelmiyor mu
şöyle yazsaydım da
herhangi bir şekilde
programın
akışında
bir değişiklik
olmayacaktı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
mesela
ayrı fonksiyonları
çalıştırmak
isteseydik
void
foo
so see out
bunu özellikle böyle
yazıyorum
foo
ar
ve bas
mesela bakın
stut vektörün
arkadaşlar
MOM
pret açılımı
rows
par
bas
Yani ben istersem
bir vektör
oluşturup
vektöre
thread nesnelerini koyabilirim.
Bunu yapmanın bir sürü
yolu var.
Daha sonradan
başıma semantiğiyle
konteynere ekleyebilirim.
Bir dizide tutabilirim.
Bunların hepsi ilerleyen saatlerde
yazacağımız koklar.
Mesela şöyle bir şey yazabilir miyim?
Elemanları
thread türünden olan
arkadaşlar
PA dizisi
4 tane
elemana sahip.
Öyle yazabilir miyim? Tabii ki.
Evet.
Bas fonksiyonu
Şimdi bakın
şimdilik onları kullanmayayım.
Thread
P1
bu
P2
var
ve T3
az.
Peki
Necati
birden fazla
thread'e
aynı fonksiyonu
çalıştırtabilir miyim?
Tabii ki.
Zaten en fazla
konuşacağımız konulardan biri
bu olacak.
O yüzden diyorum
yavaş yavaş gidiyoruz.
P1
join
P2 join
P3 join
Önce çok basit örneklerden
başlayalım ki
evet
P2 var
ve
bas fonksiyonlarının
kodu
çalıştırıldı.
Şöyle olabilir miydi?
Bakın
P2
Hatta
bir tane parametre
koyuyorum
int
x
arkadaşlar
pu
int
x
x eşit
bu
ikinci parametre
yani o
parametre paketine
argüman olarak
buna bir değerini
buna iki değerini
buna
üç değerini
göndereyim.
Orada şu anda
sadece bir tane
full fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
hemen burada
şunu da
söyleyelim
arada
kaçırmadan
şimdi bakın
pretlerin
stackleri
birbirinden ayrı
yani
fonksiyonların
içindeki
yerel değişkenler
ve parametre
değişkenleri için
herhangi bir şekilde
bir koruma
mekanizması
oluşturmanız
gerekmiyor.
Yani burada
örneğin
burayı anlamanız
çok önemli
burada örneğin
t
türünden
x
isimli bir nesne
var
türünü
olursa olsun
bu
fonksiyonu
birden fazla
thread
çalıştırırsa
burada
threadler
farklı tx
nesnelerini
mi kullanıyor
olacaklar
yoksa
aynı tx
nesnelerini
mi
cevap
tabii ki
farklı nesneleri
kullanıyor
olacak.
Yani birinci
önemli kuralımız
her threadin
stayi
kendine özgü
burası
önemli
ama bakın
eğer bir
global değişken
olsaydı
statik yerel
değişken
olsaydı
ya da
bu fonksiyonların
parametresi
örneğin
referans
olsaydı
ve ben bu
fonksiyonlara
referans
semantiğiyle
bir değişkeni
gönderseydim
o zaman
aynı
global'ı
birden fazla
thread
çalıştırdığı
zaman
bunlar
aynı değişkeni
kullanıyor
olacaktı.
Aynı değişkeni
kullandığı için
orada bir
işte o
data race
konusuna
geldiğimizde göreceğiz.
koruma mekanizması
oluşturmam
gerekecekti.
Burası
anlaşıldı mı
ama
yerel değişkenleri
için
herhangi bir şekilde
otomatik ömürlü
yerel değişkenler
ve parametre
değişkenleri için
herhangi bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizmasına
ihtiyacım yok.
Bunlar
ayrı.
Ama bakın
bu kodda
özellikle bunu
yazdım
sonuçta
siyah hatun
kendisi de
global
bir nesne.
Yani şimdi
çalışırken
T1
T2
T3
threadleri
workload olarak
aynı fonksiyonun
kodunu çalıştırırken
aynı siyah hat
nesnesini
kullanacaklar
değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Evet bakınız
derleyip çalıştırıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
niye ekran
görüntüsü
böyle oldu?
Aslında
dikkat ederseniz
ilk söylediğim
duruma çok güzel
bir örnek.
Aslında
dikkat ederseniz
yazılması gereken
her şey yazıldı.
Baksanıza
bakın
Foointix
sadece
ben
bir
senkronizasyon
oluşturmadığım
için sadece
karakter bazında
garanti var.
Mesela
buraya kadar
yazmış
ondan sonra
bu yazmış
sonra 3 yazmış
2 yazmış
1 yazmış
tekrar çalıştırdığımda
işte ben de
şunu
söylemiştim
şurayı
anlamak zorunda
değilsiniz
ama
kendi
senkronizasyonunu
kendi yapıyor.
bakın bakın
Stood
Cout
değil de
O-Sync Stream
sınıfı türünden
yetişim bir nesne
oluşturayım.
Bu
C++20 ile
eklenen
sınıf.
Bunu
isimlendirilmiş
bir yerel
nesne de
yapabilirdim.
Constructor'ına
Cout'ı
argüman
olarak vereyim.
Şimdi
artık
ne garanti
altında?
Artık
öyle
garbage
şekilde
bir ondan
yaz
bir bundan
böyle bir şey
söz konusu
değil.
kesinlikle
bunlar
ayrı ayrı
yazacak.
Ama
hangisi
önce
efendim
bir argümanla
alarak
çalıştırılan
iş
akışı
iş yükü mü
yoksa
2 mü
3 mü
o yine
deterministik
değil.
Bakın
Foo Intix
ilk önce
hangisi
çalışmış
bitmiş
sonra 2
sonra 1
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet
arkadaşlar
bir ara verelim
kaçta
ara veriyorduk?
Evet
9'da
veriyorduk
20'de
devam
edeceğiz.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
farklı yapılardaki
collable'ların
threadler tarafından
çalıştırılmasına
bir örnek verelim.
Global
bir fonksiyon
bir
function
object
bir sınıfın
statik üye
fonksiyonu
bir sınıfın
non-statik üye
fonksiyonu
mesela bakın
önce
bir
global
fonksiyondan
başlayalım
ama bütün
fonksiyonların
kodunu
aynı
yapacağım
kolay takip
edebilmeniz için
void
print
mprint
olsun
bu fonksiyonun
ismi
gmprint
itimlendirmeye
bakmayın
int
low
high
dereli aralıktaki
değerleri yazdırsın
efendim
int
i eşittir
low
i küçük
high
artı artı
i
stut
see out
i'yi
ve bir
boşluk
yazdırsın
döngüden
sonra da
efendim
bir
new line
versin
bu
gmprint
fonksiyonunun
kodu
mesela bunu
web'e çalıştırırken
doğrudan
argümanları
geçiyorum
thread
efendim
p1
gmprint
print
diyelim ki
k1
join
ikinci olarak
bir
function
object
sınıfı
oluşturalım
bir
functer
sınıf
class
functer
public
şuradan
kopyalayacağım
dikkatli bir
şekilde
fonksiyonun
ismini
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonu
yapacağım
operatör
fonksiyon
çağrı
on
dünya
fonksiyonu
olsun
arkadaşlar
ve kodu
kodu da
böyle olsun
şimdi
bunu çalıştırmak
için
thread
p2
doğrudan
geçimi
nesne
verebilirim
functer
arkadaşlar
geçi nesne
ve
argüman
örneğin
p2
join
üçüncü olarak
bir sınıfın
statik ve non-statik
yoya fonksiyonlarını
oluşturalım
class
my class
tablik
bu
statik yoya fonksiyonu
olsun
ismi
statik olduğunu
gösteren
sprint
binalan
statik yoya
fonksiyon
bu
smprint
bu da
mprint
olsun
hatta
const yoya fonksiyonu
olsun
tamam
şimdi
benim
bir
my class
nesnesine
ihtiyacım
var
değil mi
çünkü
bu fonksiyonlar
statik yoya fonksiyonu
değil ama
en azından
diğer yoya fonksiyon
bir tane
sınıf nesnesi
gerektiriyor
evet
ve
bir sınıf nesnesi
oluşturalım
my class
m
red
e3
arkadaşlar
konstruktura
statik yoya fonksiyonu
için
ne için
şurada statik fazla kalmış
evet
ne için
smprint fonksiyonu
adresi zaten örtülü olarak dönüşüyor
ve
arkadaşlar
argüman
örneğin
neç değil
my class da ismi
ben hep örneklerde neç yapıyorum ya
evet
ve
t3
join
evet
ve şimdi
non-static
üe fonksiyon
print
p4
bu sefer adres operatörünü
açıkça yazmalıyım
adres
my class'ın
m print'i
ama bir de nesneye ihtiyacım var
m
p4'ün
join fonksiyonu
bakın kolu bulu olarak farklı farklı öyler var
hatta hatta bir de
şöyle yazalım
red t5
şurada kodu alalım
şuraya yapıştıralım
biraz bekleyeceksiniz
evet
bunu
lambda ifadesi yapalım
dolayısıyla şu
const'u silelim
buradan buraya kadar
lambda ifadesi
ve
ne olsun
evet bakın
constractora gönderdiğim
birinci argüman
lambda ifadesinin kendisi
ikinci ve üçüncü argümanda
parametrelere
gönderilen
argümanlar
n print
statik oldu
onu
daha önceki kod için
söylemiş
alan
onu tüzeltmiştim
evet
t5
ve join
if
by
join
önce bakın
tek bir örnek üstünde
farklı farklı
kolumları
göstermiş olduk
sınıfın
last
statiköye fonksiyonu
için
efendim
thread sınıfının
konstruktöründe
sadece fonksiyonun
adresini değil
yıldız
dist
star dist
olarak
kullanılacak
sınıf nesnesinde
geçmem gerekiyor
şimdi
gelelim
argümanların
ve thread nesnelerinin
taşınmasına
arkadaşlar
kopyalamaya karşı
kapalı
mesela
bakınız
old
bu
see out
thread
t1
bu
şunu yazabilir miyim
auto
t2 eşit
t1
copy
construktor
deleted
ya da şöyle
yazabilir miyim
thread
t2
t2 eşit
t1
copy
assignment
yine
delete edilmiş
ama şöyle
yazabilir miyim
t1
arkadaşlar
eşittir
t1 diyorum
thread t2
ya da auto t2
eşittir
stud
move
t1
artık
taşınma
tamam
ve
arkadaşlar
t2
join
ya da
atamayla da
yapabilirdim
değil mi
evet
bakın
ya da
bakınız
thread t2
t2
mu
t1
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapalı
taşımaya
karşı
açık
bu da ne
demek
bakın
mesela şöyle
bir fonksiyon
olsaydı
buraya dikkat
bu
thread
geri dönüş
değeri
fonksiyonun
ismi
funk
olsun
parametresi
yine
stud
retöründen
olsun
ve
return
x
arkadaşlar
taşımaya
karşı
açık
olduğu için
parametreye
bitrate
nesnesini
taşımam
gerekiyor
bu bir
geçiş nesne
olabilir
r
value
expression
olabilir
x
value
expression
olabilir
pr
value
expression
olabilir
burada da
zaten
l
value
olmasına
rağmen
l
value
to
x
value
transformation
olacak
şu
çağrılardan
hepsi
bakın
thread
e
eşittir
punk
thread
u
argümandan
parametre
değişkenine
taşıma
oldu
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinden
de yine
t isimli
değişkene
taşıma
gerçekleşti
yani burada örneğin
t'nin
artık join
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirim
evet
ya da şöyle
olsaydı
thread
p
u
punk
mu
p
yine
arkadaşlar
t eşittir
böyle bile
yazabilirim
değil mi
yani
taşımanın
geçerli olduğu
her yerde
taşıma
yapabilirim
şimdi
fonksiyonun
parametresinin
referans
olması durumunda
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
iş yükü olarak
work load
olarak çalıştırılacak
fonksiyonun
parametresinin
referans olması
durumunda
eğer sağ taraf
referansıysa
zaten
taşıma
gerçekleşecek
mesela şöyle bir
kod olsaydı
void
bu
work load
bakın
fonksiyonun
parametresi
stud
vector
int
ref
vek
fonksiyonun
parametresi
sağ taraf
referansa
neyle
karıştırmıyoruz
universal
referansa
karıştırmıyoruz
ben fonksiyon
kodda
şöyle
olsaydı
for
auto
e
ya da
const
auto
e
vek
social
e
şimdi bunu çalıştıracak
ready oluşturalım
main fonksiyonun
içinde
main
elimizde bir
vector nesnesi
olsun
vector
i
vek
bir
dört
yedi
iki
üç
bir
sekiz
yedi
altı
şimdi
pret nesnesini
oluşturuyorum
pret
tx
punk
yok
word load
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
mu
ibek
şimdi
buradan
aslında
pret sınıf
nesnesini
eleman olarak
tutulacak
taşınacak
oradan da
pret sınıf nesnesi
bu fonksiyonu
çağırdığında
yine bunu
referans
semantiğiyle
sağ taraf
referans
semantiğiyle
fonksiyona
gönderecek
dolayısıyla
bir problem yok
tx
join
yerliyorum
ve
çalıştırıyorum
ama arkadaşlar
bakın
eğer
fonksiyonun
parametrisi
bu arada
aman dikkat
arkadaşlar
word load'un
parametrisinin
referans
olması
durumuna
kesinlikle
dikkat etmeniz
gerekiyor
elvelde
referans olma
durumuna
neden
e çünkü
bakın
thread
ayrı bir
akış değil mi
yani o thread'in
kodu çalışırken
sizin
o fonksiyonun
parametrisi olan
referansa
bağladığınız
değişkenin
hayatı
sona ermişse
yine
dandling
referans
oluşacak
dolayısıyla
referans
semantiğini
kullanmayın
demiyorum ama
referans
semantiğini
kullanırsanız
neden
emin
olmanız
gerekiyor
o workload
koşarken
halen
o referansın
bağlandığı
nesnenin
hayatta
olmasından
emin olmanız
gerekiyor
yani onun
başka bir
thread'te
çalıştırılıyor
olması
dandling
referans
olmayacağı
anlamına
gelmiyor
işte bunun
için
sınıfın
konstruktörü
öyle bir
şekilde
yazılmış ki
referans
semantiğini
doğrudan
uygulamanız
gerektiği
yerde
sentax
hatası
olacak
ancak
ref
sarmalayıcısını
kullanarak
yani
reference
wrapper
kullanarak
geçebileceksiniz
mesela
fonksiyonun
kodu
şöyle
olsaydı
const
studvector
int
ref
yine aynı
vektörü
kullanayım
arkadaşlar
ve
ivec
şimdi
derliyorum
ama
burada
fonksiyona
geçtim
aslında
bir kez
kopyalama yapılıyor
kopyalamadan
sonra
aktarılıyor
yani
aslında
burada
biz görmesek de
thread sınıf
nesnesini
oluştururken
aslında
thread sınıf
nesnesi
bir elemanda
bu
fonksiyona
gönderilecek
argümanı
tutuyor
o elemanda
ne
değil
referans
yani
burada
doğrudan
const
olduğu için
bir
centers
hatası
yok
ama
bir
kopyalama
var
birazdan
onu açık
bir şekilde
göstereceğim
şöyle
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
functional
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
edelim
ve
reference
wrapper
sınıfını
kullanalım
ref
ivec
evet
şimdi artık
kopyalama
söz konusu
değil
evet
tabi
referans
semantiği
nesneyi de
değiştirebilir
mesela şöyle
olsaydı
biraz kodu
değiştirelim
şuradaki
pardon
şu
constu
zaten
kaldırmak
istedim
şimdi
constu
kaldırayım
doğrudan
nesneyi
değiştirelim
range
base
for loop
şöyle
olsun
auto
ref
i
bu durumda
vektördeki
öğenin
kendisi
olacak
ne
diyelim
i
çarpı
eşit
trade
oluşturuyorum
buraya
dikkat
ibeki
bu şekilde
göndermeye
çalışayım
santaks
hatası
ama
ref
sarmalayıcısına
kullanayım
şimdi
santaks
hatası
olmayacak
arkadaşlar
bu şekilde
düzenlenmesinin
nedeni
eğer
farkında
olmadan
referans
semantiğiyle
geçildiğinde
denling
referansı
oluşturulma
ihtimali
olmasın
adeta
tür dönüştürme
operatörünü
açık bir şekilde
kullanmak gibi
yani bunu
legalde
yapabilirler de
ama bu şekilde
düzenlemelerin
nedeni bu
eğer programcı
zaten
ref fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsa
ortada bir problem
yok
ama diğeri
bir hata
sonucu da
yapılmış
olabilirdi
o yüzden
böyle bir
önlem
almışlar
şimdi
burada
vektörümüzü
yazdıralım
for
o da
i
ivek
c
alt
i
evet
onunla
çarpıldığı
için
on
kırk
yetmiş
yirmi
otuz
vesaire
oldu
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
peki
devam
arkadaşlar
şimdi özellikle
bakın şu örneği
dikkatli izlemenizi
isteyeceğim
ben
bence günün
en önemli örneklerinden
biri
bir tane sınıf
oluşturuyorum
class
match
arka planda
hangi fonksiyonların
çağrıldığını
görmenizi
istiyorum
struct match
default
constructor'ı
edeyim
default
bildirimi
yapayım
bu
copy
constructor
önemli olan
çağrıldığını
göstermek
match
copy
constructor
bu
move
constructor
match
move
constructor
buraya kadar
liderleyelim
evet
şimdi bakın
bir tane fonksiyon
void
two
parametresi
const
match
wrap
takip edin
ve
main fonksiyonu
içinde
match
türünden
yine
oluşturayım
match
x
uy'a dikkat edin
şimdi
stop
thread
kodda
neyi takip etmeniz
gerektiğini
belki söylemedim
fonksiyonun parametresi
const
match
ref
yani
const
lvalue
referans
ve ben bu fonksiyonu
çalıştıracak
thread'in
constructor'ına
bu fonksiyonun
adresini
ve x
nesnesini
geçtim
bu bir
lvalue
expression
şimdi
koda
bakın
match
copy
constructor
bu copy
neresi için
çağrıldı
cevap
thread
sınıf
nesnesi
aslında bir şekilde
argümanı
tutacak
tutarken
kopyalama
semantini
kullanıyor
zaten başka bir ihtimal
yok
ya kopyalama
ya
arkadaşlar
ne
taşıma
dolayısıyla
şimdi
kopyalama
kullanıldı
eğer bu sağ
taraftı yeri
olsaydı
rvalue
expression
olsaydı
o zaman
taşıma
gerçekleşecekti
bakın
bunu
rvalue
expression
yapayım
arkadaşlar
evet bakın
match
move
constructor
çağrıldı
ama sonuçta
fonksiyona
gönderilirken
yine
referans
semantiği
kullanıldı
şimdi fonksiyonun
kodunu
değiştirelim
fonksiyonun
parametresini
match
ref ref
yapalım
evet
ya da
ilk önce
değiştirmeyelim
bir şey eksik kaldı
şimdi
move
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak yerine
ref
fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
ve x'e
argüman olarak
gönderelim
arkadaşlar ne
kopyalama ne
taşıma
çünkü
evet kopyalama oldu
ama kopyalama
reference
wrapper
nesnesi
için oldu
reference wrapper
referans
sarmalayıcısını
hatırlayalım
dolayısıyla
fonksiyonun
thread
sınıfı
bu argümanı
tutarken
reference wrapper
nesnesini
kopyaladı
değil mi
peki
şimdi değiştirelim
fonksiyonun
parametresini
sağ taraf
referansı
yapalım
ve önce
x'i
argüman olarak
gönderelim
kopyaladı
fakat
arkadaşlar
kopyaladıktan sonra
referans
semantiği ile
geçti
evet
ya burada
ayrı bir nesne
oluşmuyor
bunu sağ taraf
değeri olarak
gönderiyor
ama
şimdi
move
x
bu sefer
gönderdiğim
sağ taraf
değeri
ne olacak
aşma
semantiği
devreye
girecek
sonra
referans
semantiği ile
aktarılacak
yani
bu şu
demek
eğer
çalıştırılacak
fonksiyona
göndereceğiniz
argüman
n value ise
ve çalıştırılacak
fonksiyonun
parametresi
n value referansa
bunu
bilerek
isteyerek
yaptığınızı
göstermek için
semantik satansı
olmamak için
referans sarmalı
için
sınıf
reference
wrapper'ı
kullanmalısınız
reference wrapper'ı
kullanmanız
gerekir
derken
zaten o
çağırdığımız
ref fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
reference
wrapper
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
bu şimdi
Google'la ilgili
bir problem
daha var
function overloading
konusu
şimdi
şöyle bir
overloading
olsa
void
who
int
evet
çağrıldığını
gösteren bir
statement
yazıyorum
yine
so see out
full
int
ama bir
orluğu daha
olsun
full
örneğin
double
spread
x
şimdi
bakın
bu
diyelim ki
burada
overload
resolution
yapma
ihtimali
yok
yani
burada
belki
şöyle
oluşan
bir
düşünebilirsiniz
gönderilen
argüman
int
olduğuna
göre
int
parametreli
bu
word
load
olarak
çalıştırıyorum
hayır
böyle bir
resolution
yapma
ihtimali
yok
ya da
böyle bir
deduction
yapma
ihtimali
yok
yine
aynı
şekilde
şöyle
yazsaydım
t1
t2
double
türden
argüman
göndersem de
sentaks
hatası
olacaktı
şimdi
bunu
arkadaşlar
yapmanın
yollarından
biri
tahmin ediyorsunuz
tür dönüşümü
explicit
type conversion
eğer fonksiyona
gönderdiğiniz argüman
ilgili türden
adres ise
biliyorsunuz bu fonksiyonun
adresi olan türle
alttaki fonksiyonun
adresi olan tür
farklı türler
ama
şöyle yazarsam
artık
bakın bakın
thread
e1
tür dönüştürme
operatörü
static cast
hangi türe
dönüştüreceğim
void
yıldız
int
bu bir
function
pointer
türü
değil mi
peki
operat ne
olacak
bu
thread t2
bu kez de
burada
türü
parametre türünü
double
yapıyorum
e1
join
t2
bir
syntax
hatası
olmayacak
ya da
doğrudan
function
pointer
değişken
kullanabilirsiniz
bu sefer
kodu biraz
değiştirelim
mesela bu
int
olsun
efendim bir tane de
yine
double
olsun
parametresi
double
olan
bir
fonksiyon
olsun
oradan
hatta
türeş
ismi de
kullanalım
using
diyelim ki
fp
type
underscore
bir
isimlendirmeye
bakmayın
efendim
void
yıldız
int
yani bu
adres türünün
bu fonksiyon adres türünün
eş ismi
ismi
diğeri
bu adres türünün
eş ismi
bu da
bu adres türünün
eş ismi
love
be
new
un
hem
ever
tane
five
daha
iyi
takip edin
diye
Mesela fp type 1. Bu parametresi int olandı.
Function pointer değişken. Eşittir.
Arkadaşlar adres foo.
fp2.
Yine adres foo.
fp3.
Burada da bir deduction oluyor değil mi?
Evet. Şimdi
yani aynı isimli fonksiyon ama burada function pointer değişkenin türünden hangisi olduğu çıkarım yoluyla elde ediliyor.
Artık şöyle yazabilirim.
Thread.
fp1 arkadaşlar.
fp1.
Bir tane argümanı vardı değil mi?
Değil mi?
Red p2.
pp2.
3.5.
Red p3.
pp3.
Şunu 3 yapalım.
dört nokta yedi.
t1 join.
t2 ve t3 join.
t3.
d2.
Verliyorum.
Evet fonksiyonların çağrılmasında herhangi bir şekilde problem yok.
Şimdi tekrar şu joinable fonksiyonuna bir geri dönelim.
Arkadaşlar ne dedik?
Eğer destraktörü çağrıldığında, thread nesnesinin destraktörü çağrıldığında eğer joinable durumdaysa o zaman terminate çağrılıyor.
Terminate abortu çağırıyor. Abort da programı sonlandırıyor. C'den gelen abort fonksiyonu.
Set terminate'i çağırırsam set terminate'de terminate'in çağıracağı fonksiyonu değiştirebiliyorum.
Benim kayıt ettiğim fonksiyon çağrılıyor.
Dolayısıyla join ya da detach fonksiyonu çağrılmadan bir iş yükü verdiğim thread nesnesinin mutlaka ve mutlaka destraktörüne çağrılmaması gerekiyor.
Aksi halde terminate çağrılacak.
Ama bir de exception gönderilen bir senaryo var.
Arkadaşlar joinable olmayan bir thread nesnesi için join fonksiyonunu çağırmak.
Mesela thread tx join.
Ama benim thread'im nedir?
Arkadaşlar joinable durumda değil.
Bu da bir hata durumu.
Şimdi yine arkadaşlar aslında terminate fonksiyonu çağırıldı.
Onu da görelim.
Ya da şöyle yapalım.
Bakalım bir exception gönderiliyor mu?
Join fonksiyonunu çağırdığım noktada eğer bir exception gönderilirse
zaten standart kütüphanenin gönderdiği exception olacak.
35. satırdaki cat glue o exception'i yakalayacak.
Bakın exception called invalid argument.
Neden?
Çünkü joinable olmayan durumdaki thread nesnesi için join fonksiyonunu çağırdım.
Tabii şöyle de olabilirdi.
Bakın şu fonksiyonlardan bir tanesi olsun.
thread tx
full
tx join
ama join fonksiyonunu çağırdığım zaman artık joinable state'ten çıktı.
dolayısıyla
yine ikinci kez join fonksiyonunu çağırdığımda exception troll etti.
akip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
arkadaşlar thread nesneslerini bir konteynerda tutabilirim dedim.
Mesela bakın void full
ne olsun
charge c
yüz kez dönen bir döngüde
u
see out
put c
evet mesela
vektör
vektörün
thread açılımı
vek
eğer
default
konstruktörü olduğu için
konstruktörün çağırılmasına bir sorun yok.
thread sınıfının
default
konstruktörü var.
Mesela
diyelim ki
10 tane
thread nesnesi oluşturulmuş olsun
vektörde
tutulan
ama
ama şu anda
hiçbirine bir word load
vermiş değilim.
a
vektörü dolaşırım
mesela for
size t
i
eşit 0
i küçük
vek
vek'in sayısı
artı artı i
vek köşeli parantesi
taşıma semantiği olduğuna göre
sağ taraf belini verebilirim.
efendim
stood thread
yer value expression verirsem
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalanacağım.
full
i
tabi şimdi
vektör nesnesinin
hayatı bittiğinde
vektör nesnesinde
tutulan
vektörde tutulan
10 tane
thread nesnesinin de
hayatı bitecek
ama bunlar
joinable durumda olduğu için
abort fonksiyonu çağırılacak.
Dolayısıyla
benim şimdi ne yapmam gerekiyor?
vektörü dolaşıp
vektörde gitti
arkadaşlar
bütün öğeler için
tek tek join fonksiyonunu
çağırmam gerekiyor.
tabi eğer
vektörde thread yerine
j thread tutsaydım
o zaman
herhangi bir problem olmayacaktık.
İzleyin şimdi
tekrar vektörü
önce
bu haliyle bir çalıştıralım.
abort fonksiyonu çağırıldı.
or
auto
bakın şöyle yazarsam da
sentaksa tasla olur.
auto
t
vek
çünkü burada da
kopyalama semantiği var değil mi?
ya şöyle yazacağım
auto
ref
t
join
şimdi problem yok.
evet
ya da
arkadaşlar
şöyle de olabilir
değil mi?
universal reference
semantini de
kullanabileceğiz değil mi?
evet
burada yine
bu pr value expression
olduğu için
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalandı.
ya da
container'a
ekleme fonksiyonlarından
birini çağırabilirdim.
mesela
default
constructor'ını çağıralım
vektör nesnemizin
ve
şöyle bir kod yazalım.
or
26 tane art parakleri var değil mi?
int i
eşittir
sıfır
i küçük
artı artı
i
pushback'in iki tane overload'ı vardı.
biri
const
r value
referans
diğeri
r value
referans.
ya şöyle yazacağım
vekin
pushback'i
ama şimdi
r value expression'i geçmem lazım
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalanmak için
stud
arkadaşlar
prep
ismi neydi?
fu
ikinci parametresine de
i
artı
a
dolayısıyla
döngünün her turunda
ne olacak?
büyük harf karakterlerinden
birini
argüman olarak
göndermiş olacağım.
büyük harf karakterlerden
birinin
kod numarasını
kod int playsini
argüman olarak
göndermiş olacağım.
tabi işim bittiğinde
for
auto
ref
p
neydi ismi?
vek
t'nin
join'i
şimdi yine bir
centrax otağısı
olmayacak.
tabi
em plays
back
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsak
em plays
back
fonksiyonuna
thread nesnesini
değil
thread sınıfının
konstraktörüne
gönderilecek
argümanları
geçmem lazım
Alihan.
Evet
şimdi
em plays
back'i
deneyelim.
em plays
back
tabi yine
thread sınıfından da
thread sınıfı
türünden de
argüman
geçebilirim
ama o zaman da
bu konstraktörün
çağrılmasını
sanacağım.
Bakın dikkat ederseniz
bu sefer
uyu ve
i artı
a'yı
geçtim.
Çünkü
yerinde
thread nesnesini
konstrakt ederken
bu argümanları
forward edecek.
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
threadlerle
ilgili
mülakatlarda
en çok
sorulan
sorulardan
bir tanesi
danding
referans
oluşumu.
Mesela
şöyle bir
kod
bir
mülakattan
olunmuş.
Bir
kodu
şimdi
incelemeye
çalışalım.
Arkadaşlar
burada
f isimli
bir fonksiyon
var.
f isimli
bir fonksiyon
olmasın.
Bu herhalde
başka bir yerden
karışmış.
Çünkü
böyle bir fonksiyon
çağrılmıyor değil mi?
Çağrıldığı bir yer
var mı?
Yok.
Main
fonksiyonu.
Yok.
Tamam.
Şimdi
koda bakalım.
F
varmış.
Evet
f
varmış
şurada.
Tamam.
şimdi
bakın
koda bakalım
danding
referans
oluşma
senaryosu
var mı
yok mu?
Funtler
sınıfının
elemanı
referans.
Dolayısıyla
elverdi
referans
demek
bir
hayatta
olan
bir nesneye
bağlı
olması
lazım.
Eğer
bu
referans
kullanıldığında
bu
referansın
bağlandığı
nesnenin
hayatı
bitmişse
bu
referans
danding
olacak.
burada
sınıfın
konstraktörü
referans
ve referans
değişkeni
veri elemanını
initialize
ediyor.
Ve dikkat ederseniz
full fonksiyonu
içinde
ibal
değişkeninin
sınıfın
konstraktörüne
argüman
olarak gönderildiğini
görüyorsunuz.
Dolayısıyla
actor
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturduk ya
burada
aslında bu
referans
ibal'e
referans.
şimdi
stu
thread
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturdum
my
functor
nesnesini
verdim ve
sınıfın
detach
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım.
Thread
sınıfının
detach
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım.
Şimdi
arkadaşlar
bu
thread
arka
planda
çalışmaya
devam
edecek.
Ana
thread'den
ayrıldı
ama
bu
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
bitti.
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
bittiğinde
ibal'in
hayatı
bitecek.
Dolayısıyla
burada
aslında
f
fonksiyonuna
gönderilen
argüman
olan referans
danding
referansı
olacak.
Danding
referansı
olduğu için
de
doğrudan
tanımsız
davranış
oluşacak.
Dolayısıyla
referans
semantiğini
kullanırken
son derece
dikkatli
olmamız
gerekiyor.
çünkü
danding
referans
oluşabilir.
Ama bakın
kopyalama söz
konusu
olsaydı
kopyalama da
herhangi bir
şekilde bir
problem
olmayacaktı.
Ditaç ve
join'in
farkını
kaçırdım
galiba
hocam.
Kısaca
farkı
nedir?
Şöyle
join
fonksiyonunu
şurada
gösterelim.
Join
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız
zaman
join
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız
noktada
bunu
o thread'i
oluşturan
thread
bloke
oluyor.
Yani
burada
join'den
sonraki
kodun
çalışması
için
artık
bu
iş yükünün
yani
t'ye
atanmış
iş yükünün
ben iş yükü
terimini
kullanıyorum.
Yani
çalıştırılan
kolumun
kodunun
çalışmasının
bitmesi
gerekiyor.
Ancak
o bitecek ki
programın
akışı
buraya
geçecek.
Ama
detach
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız
zaman
herhangi bir
şekilde
detach
fonksiyonunu
çağıran
thread'i
bloke ediyor
muyuz?
Hayır.
Burası
artmaya
devam ediyor.
O da
arka
planda
çalışmaya
devam
ediyor.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Çalışması
bitince
yine
o
kodun
çalışması
arka
planda
bitecek.
Ama
bunun
çalışması
bitmeden
kodu öyle
bir şekilde
düzenlemeniz
gerekiyor ki
bu
detach
ettiğiniz
thread'in
thread'e
atanan
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
bitmeden
bu
thread'i
oluşturan
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
biterse
o zaman
yine
arkadaşlar
orası
tamamlanmayacak.
Orada
o fonksiyonun
işini yapamadan
program
sonlanacak.
Yani
detach
artık ben
onun
sahibi
değilim
o
arka
planda
çalışsın.
Onun
artık
çalışmasına
bitmesi
için
ya
programın
sonlanması
gerekiyor
ya da
bu
thread
nesnesini
oluşturan
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışmasının
bitmesi
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
ya da
arka
planda
o çalışacak
çalışması
ne zaman
bitince
o zaman
işi
bitecek.
Yani
detach
ile onu
ayırmış
oluyoruz.
Artık
bize ait
olmaktan
çıkıyor.
Onu
kaderiyle
baş başa
bırakıyoruz.
O
arka
planda
çalışıyor.
Alihan
anlaşıldı
mı?
Ama
join'de
biz burada
bekletmiş
oluyoruz.
Yani
bu
kod
çalışacak
bitecek.
Ondan
sonra
programın
akışı
bu
noktaya
geçecek.
Evet.
Şimdi
biraz da
şu
exception
durumuna
bakalım.
Arkadaşlar
eğer
çalıştırılan
fonksiyon
bir
exception
throw
ederse
doğrudan
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrı
diyor.
Tabi
exception
throw
ederse
derken
exception
propagate
ederse
mesela
bakın
void
punk
intx
cout
bu kodu
özellikle
dikkat edelim.
cout
punk
int
hatta
intx
x eşit
x
new line
if
x mod
iki eşit eşit
sıfır
throw
std
accept'i
dahil edelim.
std
accept
throw
std
ne diyelim
invalid
argument
ya da
run
time
veriyor
yani herhangi bir
exception
göndersin.
Geçersiz
argument
şimdi
bakın
red
ax
punk
join
şu anda
exception
throw
etmeyecek.
Ama
bakın
punk
burada
exception
throw
ettiğinde
bu
exception
fonksiyondan
çıktığı zaman
termineyi
çağıracak.
Burada
kritik noktayı
anlamanız
çok önemli.
Yani
ben örneğin
burada
buraya bir
try
bloğu
içine
alsam
buraya bir de
catch
bloğu
koysam
bu
exception'i
yakalayacak
mıyım
yoksa
terminate
mi
çağırılacak?
Cevap
terminate
çağıracak.
Yani bu
exception'i
fonksiyonun
çalıştırılacak
thread tarafından
çalıştırılan
fonksiyonun
gönderdiği
exception'i
thread
nesnesine
oluşturduğum
yerde
yakalama
şansım
yok.
Daha doğrusu
yakalama şansım
yok derken
dışarı
bu şekilde
çıkarsa
yakalama
şansım
yok.
Hatta
önce
şöyle
çalıştıralım.
Bakın
şimdi
terminate
çağrıldı.
Terminate
abortu
çağırdı.
Şimdi
try
bloğu
içine
alıyorum.
Neyi
göstermek
için?
Burada
exception
yakalanmayacak.
Onu
göstermek
için.
gördüğünüz
yine
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrıldı.
Eğer ben
exception'i
burada
yakalasaydım
bir sorun
olmayacaktı.
Mesela
bakınız
bu
exception'i
burada
yakaladım.
Normal
bir fonksiyonu
kodu nasıl
çalışırsa
exception'i
yakalayan
o şekilde
çalışacak.
Yani
tekrar
eski haline
geri dönelim.
Program
lakışı
bu
exception'i
gönderildiğinde
catch
bloğunun
içine
girecek
ve
buradan
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
devam
edecek.
Fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması
join edince
bitecek.
Yani
burada
herhangi
problem
yok.
Burada
arkadaşlar
bir yerde
şu
ana blok
gitmiş
sanırım.
Evet
Fonk
gördüğünüz
exception
yakalandı.
Hatta
şurayı da
gösterelim.
Programın
akışı
buradan
devam ediyor.
Evet.
Ama
şimdi
burada
asıl
problem
şurada.
Peki
burada
gönderilen
exception'i
thread'i
oluşturan
kodda
yani
ana
thread'de
bir
şekilde
kullanabilir
miyim?
Yani
bu
exception'i
aktarmanın
yolu
varlığı.
Cevap
var.
Aslında
ben
exception
handling
konusunu
anlatırken
hatırlıyor musunuz
orada
exception
PTR
isimli
bir
sınıf
vardı.
Onunla
baktırılacağını
söylemiştim.
Özellikle
orada
o konuyu
anlatırken
exception
PTR
sınıfı
retro
exception
fonksiyonu
onun özellikle
bir
thread'ten
exception'i
o thread'i
yaratan
koda
aktarmak
için
kullanılmasının
ana senaryo
olduğunu
söylemiştim.
Şimdi ona
yönelik bir örnek
gösterelim.
Arkadaşlar
ya da
beraber
yazalım.
Bu
kod
biraz kafanızı
karıştırabilir
ama
neden?
Çünkü
o
exception
handling'teki
PTR
retro
exception
make
PTR
gibi
fonksiyonları
biliyor
olmanız
gerekiyor.
Evet.
Şimdi
nasıl bir
senaryo
kuralım?
Bir
exception'i
yakalayalım.
Evet.
Şöyle bir
kod olsun.
mesela bir
fonksiyon
void
func
int x
Dikkatli
takip edin ki
ben de yanlış
bir şey yazarsam
beni uyarın.
Önce
bunun çağrıldığını
yine gösterelim.
stut
see out
func
int x
x
eşittir
burada
buraya dikkat
try
blue'unu
alıyorum.
Ama
amacım
exception'i
burada
handle
etmek
değil
sadece
exception'i
yakalamak
ama
bunu
funk'ı
çalıştıracak
thread'e
iletmek.
burada
şöyle bir
kod yazalım
yine
if
x
mod 2
eşit
efendim
throw
stut
runtime
eriyor
sefer
bad argument.
önemli olan
exception
gönderilen exception
türünün ne olduğu
değil.
Ama bakın şimdi
bu exception'i
bu catch
blue'u yakalayacak
değil mi?
Hatta
catch
ol
tipik olarak
çünkü
burada koddan
illa standart
kütüphanenin
gönderdiği bir
exception
olmak zorunda
değil.
Ama şimdi
hangi türden
exception gönderilirse
gönderilsin
bu catch
blue'u
bunu yakalayacak.
şimdi bakın
özellikle bu
future ve promise
sınıflarını
görmeye başladığımızda
arka planda
onlarda üretilen
kodun da böyle
olduğunu
anlayacağız
ileride.
Şimdi
sınıfın
ismi neydi?
exception
ptr
stut
exception
ptr
diyelim ki
x ptr
herhangi bir
değişken
bu
nullable
bir
type
tı
null
ptr
arkadaşlar
bunun
nullable
type
olmasının
önemi ne?
Ben şimdi
herhangi bir
kodda
x ptr'nin
değerinin
null
pointer olup
olmadığına
bakacağım.
Null
pointer ise
demek ki
bir exception
söz konusu
değil.
Ama null
pointer
değilse
hatırlayın
retrow
exception
fonksiyonu ile
retrow
exception
fonksiyonu ile
bunu argüman olarak göndereceğim.
İşte bunun tuttuğu
exception'ın
tekrar gönderilmesini
sağlayacak
retrow
exception
fonksiyonu.
Şimdi ne yapıyorum?
Exception'ı yakaladığım
zaman
diğer fonksiyonun
ismi neydi?
current
exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum.
Burada
exception
nesnesini
get ediyorum
ve bunu
birinci global
nesneye
aktarıyorum.
Bu
idiomatik bir yapı.
Çok sık kullanılan.
Bir kez daha üstünden
geçelim mi?
Çünkü
yazmanız
gerekecek
birçok yerde.
Tekrar
bakalım şimdi.
Bir tane
her iki
fonksiyonunda
erişebileceği
global
bir nesne
oluşturdum.
Bu
nesne
herhangi bir
exception'ı
tutabilen
aslında
polimorfik bir
nesne
bu nesne
null pointer
durumunda
değilse
bunun
arkadaşlar
retrow
exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığında
hangi
exception'ı
tutuyorsa
onu
throw
edecek.
Ama
null pointer
state'inde ise
o zaman
retrow
exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırmayacağım.
Şimdi
bir
thread içinde
oluşan
exception'ı
dışarıya
aktarmak
istediğimde
doğrudan
aktarılmıyor.
yakalıyorum
bunu
current
exception
fonksiyonunun
geri döndürdüğü
exception
ptr'yi
bu global
nesneye
atıyorum.
Şimdi
çalıştıran
thread'e
bakalım.
Mesela
thread
px
önce
exception'ı
göndermesin.
punk
argüman
çift
sayı
değil.
Tamam.
Şimdi
bakın
thread
tx
tam
bu
kalsın.
Join
buraya
dikkat.
Ama
şimdi
iki ihtimal
var.
Ya
evet
bunun
çalışması
bitti
ama
exception'ı
yakaladı
aktarmak
için
ya
buradaki
e x
ptr'ye
yazdı
onu
ya da
e x
ptr
halen
null
pointer
durumunda.
Şimdi
şöyle bir
if
deyimi
yazsam
if
e x
ptr
bu sınıfın
hatırlayın operatör
bu fonksiyonu
vardı.
Bu ne demek
null
pointer
değilse
o zaman
retrow exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum.
Retrow exception
fonksiyonuna
e x
neydi ismi
e x ptr'yi
x ptr'yi
argüman olarak
gönderiyorum.
böylece
bu exception'ı
gönderiyor.
Dolayısıyla
burayı tekrar
bir try
bloğu
içine
aldığımda
artık
o
wordload'da
gönderilen
exception
retrow edilmiş
olacak.
Ben de
trade oluşturan
kolda
onu
işlemiş
olacağım.
izleyin şimdi.
Burada tabi
exception
gönderilmiyor
bu örnekte.
Birazdan
çift sayı
göndereceğim.
Evet
şimdi
bakın
gördüğünüz gibi
exception
yakalandı
değil mi?
Ama
nerede yakalandı?
Bu yazı
nerede çıktı?
Arkadaşlar
şurada
tekrar gönderildiği
zaman
şu
cash
bloğu
yakaladı.
Necati peki
şurayı da
gösterebilir miyiz?
Tabii
mesela burada
şöyle bir yazı
yazdırsam
exception
punk
içinde
yakalandı.
ama
punk'ın
amacı
yakalanan
exception'ı
kendisine
çalıştıran
trade'e
aktarmak.
Evet
arkadaşlar bakın
o
exception
handling
konusunu anlatırken
şöyle bir örnek
vermiştim.
Aslında
aynı örneği
şimdi artık
concurrency
konusuna
girdiğimize göre
tekrar çalıştırabiliriz.
Bu örnek
biraz daha
karmaşık.
Bu kez
exception
ptr
vektörü
var.
Yani
stud
vektör
konteynerinin
exception
ptr
açılımı
türünden
bir vektör
nesnem
var.
Bu ne
demek?
Bu
vektör
yani ismi
gxvek
olan
vektör
nesnesi
içinde
n tane
exception
ptr
tutabilir.
Dolayısıyla
şimdi
diyelim ki
ben
ana
thread
içinde
main
thread
içinde
8-9
tane
thread
oluştursam
orada
her
bir
thread
oluşabilecek
exception'i
buraya
ne yapabilirim?
Arkadaşlar
aktarabilirim.
Sonra
bu
vektörü
dolaşıp
bu
vektördeki
bütün
exception'lerin
tutulan
retrow
edilmesini
sağlayabilirim.
İşte
bunu göstermek
için
ismi
f1
f2
olan
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonlar
oluşturdum.
Takip edebiliyor
muyuz?
Bu fonksiyonlar
aslında
farklı farklı
türden
exception
true
ediyorlar.
f1
runtime
veriyor
türünden
f2
out of range
türünden
tabii
n tane
olabilir.
Ama
iki tane
yeterli
şimdi
bakın
f1
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
burada
ta
fark
exception'i
yakalıyor
ve yakaladığı
exception'i
current exception
fonksiyona
çağrı yaparak
vektöre
insert ediyor
pushback fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak.
Şimdi
burada
güzel bir noktayı
daha görmüş
oluyoruz.
Bakınız
bu nesne
global bir
nesne
değil mi?
yani bu
konteyner nesnesi
global bir
değil mi?
Evet
eğer henüz
geçmedik ama
inşallah bir dahaki
derste geçeceğiz.
Burada bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizması
olmazsa
yine
problem olacak
arkadaşlar
data race
oluşacak.
O yüzden
buradaki
kodu
şimdi anlamamız
gerekmiyor ama
buradaki
kod
o global
nesnenin
birden fazla
thread tarafından
kullanılmasına
yani bir
data race
olmadan
kullanılmasına
olanak
sağlıyor.
Ama
Necat sen
mutex
demiştin.
Evet evet
aslında
mutex'i
kullanıyoruz ama
buradaki
lock
card isimli
sınıf da
yine aynı
şekilde
bir
rayı
sınıfı.
Yani
bu sınıf
nesnesi
aslında
mutex
işini
bitirdikten
sonra
mutex
sınıfının
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmamız
gerekiyor.
Ama
unlock
fonksiyonunu
doğrudan
çağırmak
yerine
bu
rayı
sarmalayıcısını
kullanıyoruz.
Böylece
bu
lock
card
sınıfı
mutex
nesnesine
edindiğinde
onun
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor.
Ama
lock
card
nesnesinin
destructor'ı da
o konuya
geldiğimizde
göreceğiz.
Sarmaladığı
mutex'in
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor.
Böylece
şöyle
tek bir
deyimle
unlock
fonksiyonunun
çağırılmasını
ihmal etmeyecek
şekilde
kendimi
garanti altına
almış oluyorum.
Şimdi ben sadece
neye gönderme
yaptım?
Neden
buradaki
kod var?
Şu
global nesneyi
birden fazla
thread
kullanacağı için.
Peki
aynı şekilde
th
funk
thread
de
f2
çağrılıyor.
Ama
oradan
gönderilen
exception
da yine
arkadaşlar
yakalanıp
current
exception
fonksiyonu
çağrılarak
current
exception
dan elde
edilen
geri dönüş
değeri
olan
exception
ptr
o da
bu
vektöre
insert
ediliyor.
Şimdi
main
fonksiyonu
içinde
iki tane
ayrı
thread
oluşturdum.
İki
thread
çalıştırdım
join ettim.
Ama
o threadlerden
gönderilen
exception
ptr
nesneleri
global
vektörde
tutuluyor.
Vektörü
dolaşıyorum
ve vektörün
arkadaşlar
şu anda
vektör burada
evet
vektörün
bütün elemanlarını
dolaşıp
o
null
ptr
durumunda
değilse
retro
exception
fonksiyonuyla
exception'ı
tekrar gönderiyorum.
Ve
burada
aslında
benim
çalıştırdığım
koddan
gönderilen
exception'ı
o threadleri
oluşturmuş
thread'te
burada
main thread
tekrar
göndertip
onu işlemiş
oluyorum.
Yani aslında
burada bir
handle etme
söz konusu
değil.
Konuyu anladınız
değil mi?
Yani aslında
buradaki
kodun
tek amacı
exception'ı
handle
etmekten
ziyade
kendisini
çağıracak
kendisinin
çağrılmasını
sağlayacak
thread'e
aktarmak.
Bunu yapmanın
da yolu
işte bu
exception
ptr
sınıfı.
Ben
exception
entering
konusunu
anlatırken
bunu anlattım
geçmiş
derslere
bakarsanız
ama o zaman
concurrency
konusu
yoktu.
Bir
fonksiyondan
bir exception'ı
başka bir
fonksiyonda
nasıl aktarabiliriz
onu anlatmıştım
ama daha çok
bunun
uygulama alanının
birden fazla
thread olması
durumunda
söz konusu
olacağını
söylemiştik.
Şimdi
en azından
kaldığımız yeri
işaretlemek için
thread sınıfının
bütün üye
fonksiyonlarına
bir bakalım.
Thread
başlık dosyası
arkadaşlar
ve
thread
tx
Şimdi bakın
zaten çok fazla
üye fonksiyonu
yok.
Başta da
söylediğimiz gibi
join ve
detach
fonksiyonları
zaten
joinable
ve thread
için
çalıştırılmak
zorunda
join'i
çalıştırırsam
thread'in
o
yüklendiği
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışmasının
bitmesini
bekleyeceğim.
Ditech'i
çağırırsam
onu
ana thread'den
ayıracağım.
Arka planda
çalıştığı kadar
çalışsın
diyeceğim.
Arkadaşlar
her thread'in
ya da
önce şuradan
başlayalım
joinable
bull döndüren
fonksiyondu
ve
joinable
durumda ise
true'u
döndürüyordu.
Joinable
durumda değilse
false
döndürüyordu.
Bunda
önemlerdi.
Arkadaşım da
zaten ona
işaret etmişti.
Eğer
joinable
olup olmadığından
emin
değilseniz
o zaman
mecbur
joinable
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız.
Joinable
true
döndürürse
join
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız.
Neden?
Çünkü
joinable
değilken
join
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
bu sefer de
yine
hatırlayın
exception
true
edecek.
şu kalıp
bazı yerlerde
kullanılmak
zorunda.
Ama
tabii
eminseniz
joinable
olduğundan
öyle bir
sorgulama
yapmanıza
gerek yok.
Şimdi
kaldığımız yeri
belirlemek açısından
önemli bir noktaya
denelim.
Tam buradan
devam edeceğiz
şarşamba
günü.
Arkadaşlar
her
trade'in
trade'lerin
birbirinden
ayrılmasını
sağlayacak
bir
ID'si var.
Yani
örneğin
beş tane
trade
birlikte
çalışıyorsa
bunların
ID'si
birbirinden
farklı
olmak zorunda.
Main
trade'in
de bir
ID'si
var.
İşte
sınıfın
arkadaşlar
get
ID fonksiyonu
trade'in
ID'sini
get
etmek için
kullanıyor.
Böylece
bir
trade'in
hangi
trade
olduğunu
ID'sinden
sorgulayabiliyorsunuz
ya da
efendim
bunu
loglanma
vesaire
amaçla
kullanabiliyorsunuz
örnekler
vereceğim.
Yalnız
burada bir
şeye
dikkat.
Get
ID fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
int
unsigned
gibi
bir
tür
değil.
Doğrudan
trade'in
ID'si
isimli
bir
nested
type.
O
tamamen
derleyiciye
bağlı.
Yani
ben
get
ID fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
geri dönüş
değerini
bir
değişkende
tutmak
istesem
ya
auto
type
deduction
kullanacağım.
Auto
ID
eşittir.
Ya da
arkadaşlar
açık açık
şöyle yazacağım.
Trade'in
ID'si
türünden
efendim
ID
eşittir
get ID.
Yalnız bu
thread ID
sınıfı
yani
thread'lerin
ID'sini
tutan
bu
nested
type
bir
o stream'e
insert edilebilir
durumda.
Yani
get
ID fonksiyonundan
aldığım
değeri
örneğin
o stream'e
verebilirim.
Ve yine
karşılaştırma
operatör fonksiyonuyla
eşit
değil
fonksiyonlarıyla
iki
thread'in
thread ID
değişkinliğin
aynı
thread'e
ilişkin
olup
olmadığını
yani
aynı
thread'in
ID'sini
tutup
tutmadığını
sorgulayabilirim.
Evet
çarşamba
günü
kaldığımız
yerden
devam
edeceğiz.
Önce
thread
sınıfını
bitireceğiz.
Ondan
sonra şu
data
race
condition
mutual
exclusion
mutex
nesneleri
bunları
sarmalayan
luck
nesneleri
vesaire
bu
şekilde
ilerleyeceğiz.
Çarşamba
günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum.
Hoşçakalın
değerli
arkadaşlar.